commencer d'abord je voudrais remercier
l'ensemble des collègues qui sont
présents cet après-midi
je voudrais également saluer l'ensemble
des intervenants qui nous font l'honneur
de venir également je voudrais saluer
également l'ensemble des internautes qui
nous suivent en direct sur le site du
Sénat
d'abord dans l'ordre du jour on a un
premier point
sur des nominations et on va
ensuite pouvoir
attaquer le plus important
concernant donc lors du jour de notre
réunion nous devons procéder à des
désignations dans différents organismes
je vous propose de commencer donc par
ces désignations à la suite du
renouvellement de l'Assemblée nationale
l'Office doit nommer un député pour être
membre du conseil d'administration de
landra lors de sa dernière réunion le
bureau de l'Office a accueilli
favorablement la candidature de Maud
Brejon je vous propose donc de
formaliser cette nomination pas d'avis
contraire très bien l'Office doit
également désigner un député et un
sénateur pour être membre du Conseil
national de la culture scientifique
technique et industrielle
Philippe Bertha pour l'Assemblée
nationale et Angèle Préville pour le
Sénat m'ont fait part de leur intérêt de
rejoindre le CNC STI je vous propose
donc de les nommer à cette fonction pas
d'avis contraire c'est parfait enfin le
mandat de plusieurs membres de la
Commission nationale d'évaluation des
recherches et études relatives à la
gestion des matières et déchets
radioactifs plus connus sous le nom de
CN2 vient à échéance très prochainement
il revient l'office de procéder à deux
nominations j'ai reçu les CV de deux
personnes qui me paraissent tout à fait
qualifiées tout d'abord José Louis
Martinez peigna nommé au titre des
personnalités étrangères pourraient voir
son mandat renouvelé ce qui permettrait
de garantir une certaine continuité au
sein de la commission il a une carrière
universitaire bien remplie à
l'Université Autonome de Madrid il a été
directeur général adjoint de la
recherche au ministère espagnol de
l'éducation de la science il connaît
bien la France puisqu'il a été pendant 5
ans directeur associé à l'Institut le
Langevin à Grenoble
et également Jean-Paul Glatz
qui est désormais à la retraite il a
beaucoup travaillé sur la chimie des
éléments trans sur Amiens il a même
dirigé l'Institut de transurien
ité
u au sein du Centre commun de recherche
de la Commission européenne il a terminé
sa vie professionnelle comme chef du
département sûreté nucléaire du
directora sûreté et sécurité nucléaire
du Centre commun de recherche rien de
moins donc je vous propose de nommer ces
deux personnes
au cne2 pas d'avis contraire bien on en
a fini avec
le côté protocolaire je vous propose
donc de passer à notre principal ordre
du jour
concernant donc cette audition publique
sur la chlordécone les conséquences sur
la santé humaine et répercussions
sociales aux Antilles je disais cet
après-midi mais c'est encore le matin
pour ceux qui nous suivent depuis les
Antilles
en 2009 pour rappel madame procacia
sénatrice et Elvis présidente de
l'office et Monsieur le déo député
président de l'office avait établi un
premier rapport sur cette pollution qui
tâche les Antilles françaises ils y
souligné d'une part l'ampleur de ce
problème sanitaire et environnemental et
d'autre part l'importance de poursuivre
les études scientifiques et médicales
pour mesurer l'impact réel de cette
pollution et trouver des solutions de
remédiation
très en après la publication de ce
rapport l'Office fait le point sur
l'évolution des connaissances
scientifiques qui ont pu être acquises
sur ce sujet d'importance majeures une
première audition publique organisée en
février 2022 par Catherine de procacia a
été consacrée aux conséquences
environnementales de cette pollution et
aux solutions de remédiation des sols et
de sécurisation des productions
agricoles de manière complémentaire
l'audition de ce jour en temps explorer
les conséquences sanitaires de cette
pollution ainsi que les répercussions
sociales aux Antilles je précise à
nouveau donc cette audition est captée
diffusée en direct sur le site du Sénat
elle sera disponible en vidéo la demande
et par ailleurs nous en avons pris
l'habitude maintenant à l'office les
internautes ont la possibilité de
soumettre des questions en ligne par
l'intermédiaire de la plateforme dont le
lien figure sur les pages Internet de
nous en relierons un certain nombre dans
les débats que nous aurons avec nos
intervenants du jour des différentes
tables rondes je laisse à présent la
parole à la sénatrice Catherine procacia
pour introduire nos débats qui se
dérouleront sous la forme de deux tables
rondes
et merci à vous Mesdames et Messieurs
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
après la première table ronde en février
nous avons eu je l'avoue beaucoup de
difficultés à trouver une date
et c'est toujours difficile d'avoir des
intervenants à la fois les
personnalités les scientifiques qui sont
en métropole et ceux qui sont aux
Antilles dont nous avons forcément
besoin pour cette audition et je
remercie mes collègues d'être présents
et présente certains et certaines étant
très impliqués aussi sur ce dossier
alors comme le disait le Président nous
aurons deux tables ronds de successives
la première concernera les conséquences
sanitaires de cette pollution et la
deuxième les répercussions sociales la
première était consacrée vraiment aux
aspects purement de la recherche et des
avancées scientifiques
qui nous ont
associé Jean-Yves le déo puisqu'il était
il avait suivi aussi qui nous ont quand
même fait plaisir même si en 13 ans on
aurait pu espérer que la recherche
nous juste permis d'aller beaucoup plus
loin dans la dépollution des sols alors
la première table ronde
se déroulera autour de Monsieur Luc
multiné qui est directeur de recherche
de l'Inserm
à l'Institut de Recherche en Santé
Environnement et travail
qui a conduit de nombreux travaux sur la
chlordécone madame Laetitia
huardrices scientifiques de santé
publique France que
dont je fais connaissance et accompagné
de Monsieur Rosine qui est resp de la
cellule
santé publique aux Antilles Monsieur
Olivier Cunin sous directeur du travail
et de la protection sociale au ministère
de l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire et Madame Pascal Barrosso et
Monsieur Je vous aime excusez-moi Jérôme
couette chef de bureau des prestations
sociales agricoles pour le premier et
adjoint au chef du bureau des relations
et des conditions de travail de ce même
ministère alors nous allons commencer
pour cette première table ronde à donner
la parole à Monsieur mulsinier donc pour
qu'il y ait débat et organisation et des
banques entre nous avec les internautes
je propose à chacun d'entre vous
d'intervenir sur 8-10 minutes mais
monsieur Multinet en plus le professeur
Blanchet n'a pas pu se libérer
je vous accordons entre guillemets mais
si on n'est pas une ou deux minutes près
une quinzaine de minutes alors pour ce
qui ne connaissent pas
dès 1997 vous êtes penchés sur la
chlordécone
quand nous avions fait notre nos
premiers entretiens vous nous aviez
expliqué que la prévalence du cancer de
la prostate aux Antilles
n'excluaient pas que la déconne soit
aussi un facteur aggravant vous avez
continué à travailler sur l'exposition
prénatale et post-natale et l'an passé
j'ai vu des interviews de vous dans
laquelle vous parlez de la durée de vie
de la molécule dans le sang qui pouvait
s'éliminer en évitant une exposition
permanente
alors aujourd'hui
nous vous entendons pour que vous
puissiez nous présenter les travaux que
vous avez pu mener depuis 2009 ou plus
récemment comme vous le souhaiterez et
surtout qu'ils doivent permettre à
chacun et à chacune de réactualiser
nos connaissances sanitaires sur sur
l'accordéon sur la santé humaine enfant
adulte et ce que vous voulez merci
madame la sénatrice monsieur le
Président
oui nous nous sommes vus en 2009 et
depuis il s'est passé beaucoup de choses
alors je ne pourrais pas vous résumer
les à peu près 70 publications
scientifiques qui ont été produites
sur la problématique leur déconne et
tout son environnement parce que voilà
mais je vais essayer néanmoins d'être le
plus
synthétique possible dans le temps que
vous m'avez imparti
je pense que je voudrais débuter quand
même par un peu les circonstances dans
lequel les connaissances ont été
acquises et je tiens à préciser que je
vais parler de risque pour la santé
alors je ne sais pas s'il vous
présentation qui vous est affiché ou pas
je pensais que cela allait être fait
mais ça n'a aucune aucune espèce
d'importance d'importance
oui j'ai intitulé Mon propos liminaire
qu'elle risque pour la santé de la santé
des populations je parle bien de
connaissances des risques dans le cadre
de la recherche médicale et pas dans le
cadre des risques de l'évaluation des
risques ce qui est fait par les agences
sanitaires
la question des risques sanitaires a été
posée dès 1999 au moment où on a
redécouvert la pollution de
l'environnement au chlordécone celui de
la chaîne de trophique et des denrées
alimentaires tiens vous rappeler que le
risque de produit d'un danger
intrinsèque mais aussi d'une exposition
en 1999 nous avions beaucoup de
connaissances sur la nature des dangers
du chlore bacon établit au cours des
années 70 et 80 son potentiel
reprotoxiques ça neurotoxicité sa
toxicité développementale chaque
cancérogénicité et son caractère
hormonal en tant que perturbateur
endocrinien par contre nous n'avions
absolument aucune information sur les
niveaux d'exposition de la population
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
première chose que nous avons entrepris
assez rapidement c'est de pouvoir
développer un outil celui de la mesure
de chlorecome dans le sang que nous
avons fait dans le cas d'un partenariat
avec l'Université de Liège
puisque la mesure du chlore dans le sang
est un bon indicateur de la charge
corporelle et deux premières études
l'une réalisée chez des travailleurs
salariés agricoles et non agricoles mais
aussi parmi des femmes enceintes et des
nouveaux-nés nous ont permis assez
rapidement d'une part de constater la
présence de chlore des comes dans la
grande majorité des populations étudiées
d'observer que le chlordé le plus
fréquemment retrouvé parmi ce mesurer et
au niveau les plus élevés de montrer le
passage transplantaire mais aussi même
si de façon plus modeste dans le lait
maternel mais aussi et ça c'est
important d'exclure la survenue du
syndrome neurotoxique du keperen qui
avait été décrit aux États-Unis chez les
travailleurs intoxiqués par la molécule
en constatant que les niveaux moyens de
la population à l'époque était entre 10
à 1000 fois inférieur à celui qui
déclenche ce syndrome
une fois que nous avons eu donc ces
premières connaissances sur les niveaux
d'exposition nous nous sommes posés une
deuxième question mais quel danger
quelle maladie allons-nous étudier parce
que bien sûr il s'agissait pas de faire
un choix alors nous avons tenu compte
bien l'ensemble du profil toxicologique
de la molécule telle que je viens de
vous le dire de la prévalence des
maladies dans les territoires antillais
mais vous s'intéressez à des maladies
qui sont très fréquentes parce que sur
une maladie très rare il est très
difficile de tirer des conclusions c'est
une question de bon sens et puis un
troisième élément qui est la faisabilité
des recherches tenant compte d'abord de
nos propres compétences mais aussi des
ressources locales
c'est ainsi que nous avons tenant compte
de tous ces éléments orienter nos
recherches majoritairement mais pas
totalement sur des atteintes non
cancérogènes touchant soit la fertilité
soit la grossesse et le développement de
l'enfant développement prénatal et
postal et s'agissant des atteintes
cancérogènes nous nous sommes intéressés
au cancer de la prostate du fait de sa
prévalence élevée son caractère
hormonodépendant ce qui peut être
pertinent au regard des propriétaires
hormonal du chlordécone
alors pour résumer en matière de
fertilité et de fertilité masculine une
étude réalisée donc assez tôt la
première vers les années 2000
a montré clairement que les niveaux
d'exposition de la population donc
masculine adulte n'était pas associé ni
aux caractéristiques de sperme ni au
délai nécessaire à concevoir un enfant
dans le couple qui formait
cependant des études beaucoup plus
récentes de type expérimentales qui ont
été réalisés par notre institut ont
montré que lorsqu'on expose des souris
au cours de leur gestation au chlore des
codes et bien cela entraîne chez la
portée mâle une diminution de la
production spermatique au moins jusqu'à
la troisième génération alors ces
altérations sont probablement associées
à des modifications épigénétiques et
souligne en tout cas
un danger potentiel d'ordre
transgénérationnel alors c'est pas
exclusif il faut que leur déconne c'est
une problématique qu'on commence à
connaître depuis de nombreuses années
mais en tout cas qui nous montre qu'il
ne suffit pas de ne pas observer un
problème lié chez l'adulte suite
probablement une exposition adulte mais
voilà on a encore aussi des risques qui
seront tout de toute façon très très
difficile à mettre en évidence sur un
plan épidémiologique s'agissant de la
fertilité féminine aujourd'hui on a une
absence de données car il n'y a eu
aucune étude mise en place pour
différentes raisons et tous les
pdmiologiques néanmoins nous nous
projetons dans un très proche à venir de
nous occuper de cette question ici
encore des travaux expérimentaux récents
toujours chez la souris gestante ont
montré que une exposition donc pendant
cette période
entraînait chez la portée femelle des
atteintes du développement des
follicules ovariens
et ces altérations ici encore associées
à des modifications épigénétiques donc
ça pose la question nous n'avons pas de
réponse sur cet aspect mais ça fait
partie des études qui sont en cours de
développement
ensuite je vous ai dit c'est l'aspect
grossesse développement après le postale
alors pour cela nous nous sommes appuyés
sur une corde mère enfant qui a débuté
sur la période 2004 2007 bien sûr les
ont accouché 9 mois plus tard dans cette
période là et les enfants ont fait
l'objet d'un suivi et très prochainement
dès le mois de novembre nous devrions
débuter un suivi à l'âge de
l'adolescence entre 15 et 17 ans
alors là nous avons observé beaucoup de
choses mais je tiens aussi à vous
signaler les absences de risque parce
que bien sûr on parle toujours des
trains qui arrivent en retard il y en a
certains qui arrivent à l'heure quand
même
et ça c'est important nous avons nous
n'avons pas observé de risques liés à
une exposition de la femme enceinte au
regard d'un certain nombre de
pathologies classiques diabète
hypertension gestationnelle près comme
si mais aussi ça c'est très important de
malformation qu'en génitales parce qu'il
y avait eu beaucoup de bruit et
d'inquiétude à ce sujet et là c'est pas
là que le risque par contre des travaux
postérieurs ont clairement montré que
cette exposition pouvait entraînée un ce
risque de survenu de prématurité de
réduction de grossesse et chez les
enfants nous avons observé un ensemble
de de données certaines qui se sont
confirmés d'autre part par exemple sur
le plan anthropométrique on sait on a
observé des effets sur l'indice de masse
corporelle des des chez les filles et
garçons entre la naissance et 18 mois
mais dans un suivi récent enfin d'une
publication récente correspondant à un
suivi à l'âge quelques temps nous
n'avons plus observer ce phénomène par
contre quelque chose qui se maintient au
cours du temps ce sont ces l'impact sur
le neuro-développement des enfants que
ça soit moteur cognitif
ainsi par exemple à différents âges donc
des moins boscopes moins bons score
estimant par exemple alors c'est des
notions techniques excusez moi mais la
préférence visuelle pour la nouveauté la
motricité fine le traitement de
l'information visuelle la sensibilité au
contraste visuel et nous avons encore
des études qui sont actuellement soumis
à publication et qui vont compléter ce
dispositif alors ce ne sont pas des
maladies en tant que tel mais montre
bien qu'il y a quand même un impact sur
le nouveau développement des enfants
là aussi une étude alors avec des outils
très moléculaires mais réalisé chez les
nouveaux-nés de l'accord tuttimoun on a
observé en analysant le ADN qu'il y
avait une des modifications de la
distribution de certaines marques et
puis génétiques je rentre pas dans les
détails laissant à penser que le
chlordécone a des effets
donc sur ces modifications
épidénétiques sans que pour autant
aujourd'hui on sache les traduire en
effet sanitaires à terme
troisième volet celui du cancer de la
prostate que vous avez évoqué qui
effectivement ont été conduits et se
poursuivre en collaboration proche avec
le professeur Pascal Blanchet
des publications ont montré les
premières en 2010 que l'exposition des
hommes adultes donc bien sûr au
chlordécone était associé à un excès de
risque c'est significative de survenue
du cancer de la prostate
il nous avait été demandé par le
professeur dédié Houssin à l'époque
directeur de directeur général de la
Santé de pouvoir réaliser une étude
similaire en Martinique ayant été
conduites en Guadeloupe
malheureusement nous n'avons pas pu
la conduire à ses fins puisque les
financements qui nous avaient été
attribués ont été interrompus c'est à ce
moment-là qu'on s'est intéressé un autre
aspect toujours en relation avec le
cancer de la prostate mais non pas la
survenue mais ce qui devient après
comprenez patient qui a un cancer on le
soigne et un des risques un cancer c'est
qu'il y ait une rechute qui est une
récidive et donc nous sommes intéressés
à la récidive de cancer de la prostate
et là nous avons également montré
comment le chlore bacon de façon assez
spécifique est associée à un excès de
risque de récidive de cancer de la
prostate
tout cela donnait un ensemble assez
cohérent en tant que promoteur tumoral
de la molécule et encore la plus
récemment nous avons complété ces
observations avec des études
expérimentales toujours sur la souris
c'est le modèle de effet
transgénérationnel et épigénétique
classique c'est un standard et bien
cette étude a montré que l'exposition
des femelles bien sûr
gestationnel entraîné chez la portée
mâle une augmentation des lésions qu'on
appelle
préeoplasique en tout cas oui voilà
et ce jusqu'à au moins la troisième
génération
et que c'est l'échillons apparaissent
également corrélés à des modifications
des caractéristiques et puis génétiques
alors certes dans le cas de l'étude sur
le cancer de la prostate étant donné que
tous les hommes étaient nés avant le
début d'utilisation du plan d'école si
on prend cette date d'utilisation en
1973 on peut considérer que l'ensemble
de nos travaux ont été conduits sur une
exposition chez l'individu adulte
la question des effets
transgénérationnels se posent à partir
de 1973 mais bien sûr ne se
manifesteront que lorsque ces hommes-là
atteindront la soixantaine donc il va
falloir attendre quelques années ça sera
là aussi sur un plan épidémiologique
toujours très compliqué à mettre en
évidence mais tout cela et c'est une
conclusion de
tous ces observations essayez d'être
synthétique
mène finalement à faire tout le
nécessaire pour que la population et les
sous populations ne soient plus exposées
aux chlore des connes alors ce n'est pas
une tâche facile mais il faut faire
évidemment
son maximum alors il y a un site
internet de notre institut je vous
transmettrai le lien il a déjà été
monsieur je l'avais transmis ou tout
ceci est résumé disons pour le grand
public de façon un peu plus détaillée je
voudrais conclure parce que ça c'est
important en tant que chercheur à
l'INSERM c'est bien d'acquérir de la
connaissance mais il faut que tout cela
ait de la portée sanitaire alors
comment peut-on décliner je finirai par
là bien sûr c'est
identifie ou écarter les risques en
termes de connaissances c'est cela nos
études l'ont permis de suivre
l'évolution des expositions au cours de
temps montant montrant que
progressivement les niveaux d'exposition
diminué et là de santé publique France
s'exprimerait tout à l'heure pour
justement à travers les études de
biosurveillance montrait cela de façon
éclatante et puis le troisième point
bien sûr auquel nous avons toujours
veillé par des échanges avec tous les
acteurs de santé c'est pouvoir apporter
les informations pour l'évaluation de
gestion des risques et je citerai par
exemple
les recommandations qu'a fait la star
concernant l'allaitement maternel et la
contamination de l'implantécone en 2008
l'avis de la haute la vie de la Haute
Autorité de Santé sur le dépistage du
cancer de la prostate en 2012
l'expertise collective inchère
pesticides santé
avec le chapitre cancer de la prostate
et que leur déconne de 2021 l'expertise
collective de l'un de ces maladies
professionnelle cancer de la prostate en
lien avec les pesticides de 2021 et le
travail
qu'a réalisé l'enses sur les valeurs
sanitaires de référence également publié
en 2021 voilà ce que je voulais vous
dire de la façon la plus synthétique
possible
merci beaucoup professeur alors nous on
doit vous présenter les excuses parce
que si je comprends bien
le logiciel
a changé hier et on a quelques soucis
pour projeter les documents que qui
devait accompagner votre propos alors ce
que je propose et je pense que c'est
possible c'est que dans le dans le
compte-rendu et en tout cas dans
le Replay qui pourrait être vu sur le
site du Sénat de l'Assemblée nationale
de l'opère on puisse s'intégrer les les
documents que vous vouliez nous nous
présentons dans mon cas je vous préciser
que ce n'était que la reprise de ce que
j'ai exprimé d'ailleurs je me suis servi
de ces meubles diapos pour lire voilà
très bien pas un schéma explicatif
particulier qu'on aurait l'expression
orale aurait été difficile à traduire
alors je vous propose qu'on passe la
parole tous les intervenants et qu'après
on passe aux questions qui pourront se
porter sur ce que vous souhaitez donc
maintenant je vais vous avez
parfaitement fait la liaison avec santé
publique France
et donc vous êtes penchés depuis de
nombreuses années à santé publique
France sur sur l'accord d'école vous
avez participé au plan national de lutte
contre l'accordéon vous vous êtes
penchés sur la santé des travailleurs
des bananerais vous avez suivi l'étude
canari donc je vous laisse là aussi
présenter les études sur la corde école
sachant qu'en 2009 au moins vous n'étiez
point à sentier public France en tant
que tel sous ce nom n'existe pas
mesdames Messieurs les sénatrices et les
sénateurs maisdames Messieurs les
Députés madame la Présidente je vous
remercie donc je suis Laetitia huyère je
suis directrice scientifique de santé
publique France je suis professeur de
santé publique et de formation
épidémiologistes
je n'étais pas là tout court et donc je
vais vous raconter une étude une
histoire que je n'ai pas vécue dans
l'agence mais et j'ai retravaillé dans
le dans l'historique de l'agence donc
qui est chargé de la surveillance et de
la protection des populations et j'ai
choisi des exemples d'études qui
illustrent l'action de l'agence pour à
la fois appuyer les politiques publiques
et pour l'accompagnement des des
populations dans leur dans leurs
habitudes de consommation individuelle
qui sont un enjeu assez majeur dans
cette problématique qu'on aborde
aujourd'hui
alors vous voyez du coup pas mes
diapositives mais je sais voilà je vais
être obligé de faire avec parce que j'en
ai besoin pour vous amener dans le dans
ce propos là
je voulais parler de plusieurs travaux
qui ont été réalisés de quelques-uns qui
sont en cours et en cours de clôture et
qui pour certains seront présentés en
décembre à la Guadeloupe
donc dans les travaux qui ont été
conduits par l'agence il y a l'étude
tout d'abord je vais vous parler des
études map Phyto rapidement de canarien
canari 2 d'évaluation des programmes
Jafa et d'élaboration des nouveaux
messages sur les recommandations de
consommation alimentaire donc sur
l'étude
matfito c'est une étude qui avait été
mis en place à l'agence qui repose à la
fois sur
l'utilisation de matrice culture
exposition qui sont des bases de données
internes à santé publique France de
donner des qui proviennent des
recensements agricoles aux Antilles qui
permettent de caractériser les
populations de travailleurs
de la banane sur sur ce territoire qui
sont des données externes à Grest et
puis qui permettent d'estimer des
indicateurs d'exposition au pesticides
donc le pourcentage et le nombre de
travailleurs agricoles exposés à chaque
pesticides c'est un des travaux qui ont
été importants puisque c'est ces travaux
de reconstruction d'exposition permet de
reconstruire des expositions historiques
de personnes qui qui ont pu être exposer
professionnellement à la chlordécone ou
à d'autres pesticides et c'était dans
cette étude pour la première fois le
recensement de tous les pesticides qui
ont été utilisés sur la banane aux
Antilles entre 1960 et 2015
et une soixantaine de pesticides ont
ainsi pu être pu être explorés en 89
donc il y a eu sur les 12700
travailleurs agricoles de la banane aux
Antilles il a été identifié que 77%
d'entre eux ont été possiblement exposés
à la chlordécone
donc ces travaux ils sont importants
parce qu'ils ont pu être exploités d'une
part pour caractériser les expositions
des travailleurs agricoles
identifiés dans le cadre de l'accord de
reconstitué par l'Inserm qui est la cote
corps des travailleurs agricoles de la
banane potentiellement exposés à chlore
des cônes et qui permettent du coup de
de produire des valeurs d'exposition et
de permettre aux équipes de recherche
ensuite de de
travailler sur les l'impact sanitaire de
ces de ces expositions
je voulais vous parler de l'étude canari
1 en particulier de son volet
imprégnation puisque cette étude c'est
la première étude en population générale
qui permet de disposer de donner sur la
distribution des niveaux d'imprégnation
à la chlordécone et sur les déterminants
de ces imprégnations les données ont été
recueillies sur la période 2013 2014 et
le rapport a été produit en 2018
les trois résultats qui sont importants
dans cette étude le premier résultat
c'est que ça montre que les niveaux
moyens d'imprégnation sont comparables à
la Guadeloupe et à la Martinique que la
chlordécone et les composés
organochlorés ont été détectés
c'est-à-dire il y a que ça aille de
traces soit au niveau élevé chez 90 %
des participants ce qui veut pas dire
que il y a 90% des personnes qui ont un
impact sanitaire de l'exposition mais on
retrouve
du produit qui a des seuils variables
chez une grande partie des participants
et de façon
des travailleurs ou c'est tout là on est
sur la population générale et le
résultat qui était intéressant dans
cette étude là c'est que 5% des
participants ont une imprégnation qui
est dix fois plus élevée que
l'imprégnation moyenne donc une grande
variabilité d'imprégnation et un niveau
élevé pour une
proportion de 5% qui est qui est
importante
l'autre élément très important c'est que
le niveau d'imprégnation
ce qu'on a pu mettre en évidence c'est
qu'il varier en fonction
de la consommation alimentaire notamment
la consommation totale de poissons frais
en particulier dans les circuits
informels de distribution le fait de
résider dans une zone de contamination
terrestre par la chlordécone ou le fait
de résider dans en proximité d'une zone
de contamination maritime par la par la
chlordécone
plus largement
cette étude canari elle a permis de
vraiment d'avoir une description des
niveaux d'imprégnation à la chlordécone
dans la population générale avec une
détection de leur déconne dans une large
proportion de la population et avec une
variabilité importante et dont l'impact
étant étant étant et vraiment à définir
précisément en fonction des niveaux
d'identifier les principaux aliments et
circuits de distribution contributeurs
dans l'imprégnation d'appuyer les
travaux de lances pour pouvoir évaluer
les risques liés à l'exposition par la
voie alimentaire principalement et donc
l'établissement de valeurs de
psychologique de référence interne en
particulier merci
donc qui sont vraiment très importants
justement pour pouvoir passer de la
notion de détection d'exposition à
qu'est-ce qui fait du sens en terme
d'impact et d'émettre des
recommandations sur les habitudes
alimentaires donc des travaux très
importants par l'inceste qui ont été
mentionnés
avec le rapport donc sur ces valeurs
toxiques de référence et puis des
résultats qui seront aussi présentés en
décembre et qui permettront de revoir
par rapport à ces valeurs seuils quelle
est la proportion de la population qui
est effectivement au-dessus de ses
valeurs
il y a
au-delà de ces données qui sont de
risque il y a eu aussi la possibilité de
préciser des recommandations les
recommandations qui ont été donnés aux
bénéficiaires des programmes Jafa donc
les jardins familiaux pour pouvoir
accompagner la population sur les
aliments à consommer la fréquence les
les
possibilités de culture ou le ou le
comment cultiver en limitant les risques
donc ça c'est les travaux qui ont été
qui ont été conduits dans les travaux
qui sont en cours donc du côté de santé
publique France et qui s'inscrivent dans
le plan corps des plans national colorés
comme 4 il y a l'étude canari 2 donc il
y a pour objectif de décrire l'évolution
de la distribution des niveaux
d'imprégnation puisqu'on a le
référentiel de canarien et on aura des
nouvelles mesures d'encannari 2 et puis
les deux au-delà de la fleur d'école les
autres polluants évidemment d'intérêt
pour la population générale
de rechercher et préciser les
déterminants qui sont liés à cette
imprégnation
de décrire les caractéristiques
d'imprégnation des sous-groupes les plus
sensibles les enfants les femmes en âge
de procréer les travailleurs agricoles
et puis de s'intéresser tout
particulièrement au groupe justement des
plus exposés comme on a pu le mentionner
auparavant et de d'identifier les
caractéristiques de ces personnes qui
sont plus fortement exposées dans le
dans cette étude là
un deuxième travail qui est conduit à
santé publique France va être
l'évaluation du programme Jafa donc
c'est évalué l'impact du programme Jafa
et analyser les conditions de son
efficacité afin de pouvoir faire des
recommandations pour optimiser et
développer le programme à plus grande
échelle et enfin on a un travail
important qui a été débuté sur
l'élaboration de nouveaux messages sur
les recommandations et les consommations
alimentaires pour lequel on a mis en
place un comité qui est composé c'est un
comité santé publique France qui est
composé d'acteurs locaux et nationaux
qui
travaillent dans une approche évidemment
scientifique comme comme les travaux
conduits par l'agence
avec un panorama de la littérature entre
premier lieu évidemment sur les
déterminants notamment de la confiance
dans les messages de santé publique et
les leviers possibles pour accroître
cette confiance puisque c'est un enjeu
évidemment majeur dans ces
recommandations à une des premiers temps
de ces travaux c'est une étude
qualitative auprès de la population des
Antilles pour actualiser la
compréhension des freins et des leviers
par rapport aux recommandations
sanitaires de tester des messages
existants d'explorer les déterminants de
la confiance dans les recommandations
d'évaluer la possibilité de co-création
de messages alors j'ai on a les premiers
résultats de cette étude qualitative
c'est évidemment des résultats qui sont
pas des nouveautés scientifiques c'est
des choses qui sont connues mais qui
sont importantes de pouvoir de pouvoir
formaliser et écrire parce que c'est ce
qui permet aussi de travailler la suite
et de partir de de ces éléments
on s'assurant qu'il soit prise en compte
dans la suite des travaux donc les
freins de l'adoption qui ont été
rapportés par les personnes qui ont été
enquêtées dans cette étude qualitative
c'est évidemment notion de déni de
sentiment de fatalité de scepticisme dû
à la répétition des crises sanitaires et
à l'emploi généralisé des pesticides une
faible légitimité des discours officiels
voire une défiance vis-à-vis de la
parole publique un attachement culturel
fort à la pêche locale et aux pratiques
culturelles issues déjà du jardin créole
avec des changements qui sont qui sont
perçus comme des sentiments de perte
d'identité un découragement car des
difficultés à la mise en pratique des
recommandations et puis des surcoûts
économiques qui sont liés au changement
de pratique et de consommation voilà les
premiers éléments et ça sera présenté
plus en détail en décembre lors du lors
du colloque scientifique à la Guadeloupe
mais c'est des éléments à partir
desquels on souhaite co-construire
ensuite la suite et des messages et des
et des et des recommandations qui soient
qui qui soit
utile à la population donc voilà un peu
les éléments que j'avais sélectionnés en
premier lieu pour vous
illustrant ces deux axes un peu d'appui
à la politique publique et et
d'accompagnement des populations dans
leur dans leurs habitudes de
consommation individuelle
merci merci Madame
vous nous inciter fortement est-ce que
le colloque sera en visio où il faudra
être vous ne savez pas encore
qu'on puisse le suivre
éventuellement nous sommes nous ne
sommes pas les organisateurs
il semble qu'il sera effectivement
accessible également en vision merci
avec les problèmes de décalage horaire
[Rires]
donc
maintenant nous allons passer la parole
à un monsieur
cnin et
sur le cancer de la prostate en 2021 il
a été reconnu comme une maladie
professionnelle pour les travailleurs
agricoles qui sont exposés c'était une
c'était une avancée et
ça a été une une première
donc monsieur vous êtes en dessous je
l'ai rappelé tout à l'heure sous
directeur du travail et de la protection
sociale au ministère de l'Agriculture
et vous êtes accompagné donc de Madame
Pascal Barroso et de Monsieur Jérôme
cohet je vous laisse vous organiser tous
les trois et intervenez comme vous le
souhaitez pour nous dire
ce qu'il en est sur le plan des
ministères et par rapport à
au point de la reconnaissance de la
chlordécone comme maladie en tout cas
les maladies
merci Madame présidente pour comme il
faut une introduction en fait on va dire
raccourci je vais me permettre
d'intervenir seul et puis ensuite avec
les collègues on pourra répondre aux
questions donc je vous remercie pour
cette invitation vous nous avez demandé
d'intervenir effectivement sur la
création du tableau de ma vie
professionnelle liée enfin sur le cancer
la prostate liée à l'exposition aux
pesticides
et donc voilà je pense que c'est
effectivement une conclusion claire
monsieur le professeur vous indiquez
tout à l'heure que les connaissances
devaient servir à améliorer en fait les
décisions et avoir des impacts donc je
pense que en l'espèce c'est le cas
peut-être rappeler que au sein du
ministère de l'Agriculture donc
évidemment là on s'occupe de d'un sujet
sur la réparation mais on a aussi des
actions en termes de protection et de
prévention des populations pour essayer
de limiter l'exposition à l'accord des
codes mais là on va se focaliser dans ma
présentation sur la création de ce
tableau de maladie professionnelle
aujourd'hui avant la création de ce
tableau il existe déjà des tableaux de
maladies professionnelles liés à
l'exposition aux pesticides je pense
notamment au tableau 58 et 59 sur la
maladie de Parkinson et les lymphomes
donc les déjà des tableaux mais il en
existait pas pour le cancer de la
prostate peut-être pour vous rappeler
comment
émergent la création de ces tableaux
donc c'est le tableau de ma vie
professionnelle sont proposés par une
commission paritaire qui s'appelle la
cosmap pour l'agriculture la commission
supérieure de maladies agricoles qui
sont une instance paritaire avec des
organisations patronales des
organisations salariales mais également
des associations de victimes et des
organismes scientifiques et des
personnalités qualifiées des docteurs
donc il y a notamment Sanchez puis
participe aux travaux de la cosmap et
c'est cette commission qui a en charge
de proposer au gouvernement la création
de tableaux de maladies professionnelles
depuis 2018 il y a eu une nouvelle
doctrine pour élaborer ses tableaux de
ma vie professionnel tant au régime
général corrigé agricole puisque
il est demandé à ce que ces tableaux
s'appuient préalablement une expertise
scientifique collective et indépendante
et c'est pour cela que systématiquement
désormais nous sollicitons la vie de
lancès avant de débattre sur la création
d'un tableau et on s'est également
appuyé enfin la cosmap c'est également
appuyé sur l'étude que vous avez cité
également tout à l'heure
l'étude de l'Inserm pesticide est fait
sur la santé donc une étude qui faisait
un large bilan des effets sur la santé
des pesticides donc il a dû être
actualisé puisque les connaissances en
la matière évoluent assez fortement et
donc cette étude a été prise en compte
tout comme la vie de Lancel et ont été
présentés
en juin et juillet 2021 est présenté
aussi aux membres de la cosmap en avril
2021 sur cette base là les membres de la
cosmap ce sont réunis en
le jour de travail et puis en octobre
2021 on statué pour lors de la Cosma du
12 octobre indiqué que il demandait la
création d'une d'un tableau de maladie
professionnelle cancer de la prostate
lié à l'exposition en pesticides et ils
ont proposé ou non des paramètres
puisque dans un tableau on va le voir
tout de suite il y a différents
paramètres et donc sur les paramètres il
y avait pas forcément de consensus mais
en tout cas il y avait un consensus
trouver assez rapidement puisque six
mois après la présentation des résultats
fin de l'étude de lancès la cosmap était
unanimement d'accord pour la création de
ce tableau et donc ils ont indiqué la
Cosma va indiquer au gouvernement on
vous propose de créer un tableau de ma
vie professionnelle maintenant sur les
paramètres on a débattu et on n'est pas
complètement c'est pas complètement
consensuel donc ce tableau le
gouvernement sur cette proposition a
pris un décret pour effectivement créer
ce tableau de maladie professionnelle
donc décret du 20 décembre 2021
un tableau est constitué de trois
colonnes qui permettent ensuite
d'obtenir la reconnaissance donc d'abord
la désignation de la maladie cancer de
la prostate détaillerait pas tellement
de débats sur le sujet
rappelez néanmoins qu'on est sur un
tableau qui est l'exposition au
pesticides c'est pas uniquement
l'exposition La chlordonne et là-dessus
c'est important de le souligner puisque
l'unsest nous avait très indiqué de
manière très claire que il n'avait pas
de sens à créer un tableau uniquement
sur l'exposition à l'accordéon compte
tenu de la
de la fin du fait que tu as fait
d'autres pesticides qui pouvaient
entraîner ces cette maladie et qui a des
interactions aussi entre les pesticides
voilà donc ça c'est je pense que c'est
important de le rappeler donc c'est un
tableau qui est concerne l'exposition
aux pesticides la deuxième colonne du
tableau c'est le délai de prise en
charge et c'est sur cette colonne qu'il
peut y avoir des débats puisque les avis
scientifiques ne sont pas forcément très
clairs puisqu'ils peuvent pas forcément
être très clairs sur ce type de critères
donc le délai de prise en charge c'est
de délai entre la fin de l'exposition et
l'apparition de la maladie donc là le
choix qui a été fait c'est de prendre
des 40 ans c'est à dire que si la
maladie pardon se déclare entre la fin
de la session de d'exposition donc la
fin de fin à la retraite on va dire pour
un exploitant agricole ou un travailleur
agricole et 40 dans les 40 ans c'est la
maladie se déclare alors on remplit
cette condition du tableau donc là
dessus il y avait il y avait un petit
débat l'anxess nous indiquer que il
fallait un délai d'au moins 10 ans et
que nous le recommander de nous baser de
s'appuyer sur les données relatives aux
autres cancers solides figurant dans les
tableaux et en pratique c'est 30 ans ou
40 ans
deuxième condition de cette deuxième
colonne c'est la durée d'exposition donc
c'est la durée pendant laquelle
l'exposition enfin le travailleur
l'assuré on l'espèce a été exposé et
donc là la durée qui a été retenue c'est
une durée de 10 ans c'était un peu plus
consensuel mais c'était pas non plus il
y a pas eu non plus sur le sur le sujet
et enfin la troisième colonne du tableau
c'est la liste indicative des principaux
travaux et donc très très concrètement
c'est tous les travaux agricoles en est
avec des pesticides que ce soit la
manipulation l'utilisation de nettoyage
et y compris des contacts avec les
cultures ou les surfaces qui ont été
exposées aux pesticides donc le tableau
a été adopté maintenant comment ça se
passe quand il y a un tableau les
personnes qui n'ont souffrent du cancer
de la prostate peuvent demander une
reconnaissance en maladie
professionnelle deux options soient
remplissent la totalité des conditions
du tableau et auquel cas ils sont
reconnus automatiquement soit ce n'est
pas le cas et donc il passe par une
commission régionale de reconnaissance
de maladie professionnelle sauf que pour
le tableau
le cancer de la prostate avec
l'exposition en pesticide en fait on
s'inscrit dans le fond d'ananisation des
victimes de pesticides puisque le fond
de la méditation des victimes de
pesticides est un dispositif
d'indemnisation qui s'appuie sur les
régimes d'accident du travail de maladie
professionnelle
mais qui vient les améliorer et donc une
des améliorations de ce fond
d'indemnisation des victimes de
pesticides que je me permettrais appelé
front pesticide pour aller plus vite ce
fond pesticides donc a décidé de créer
une commission unique de reconnaissance
des maladies professionnelles parce
qu'un des biais qui était
qui était critiquée était que il peut y
avoir autant de commissions régionales
qui a de région et de fait sur le même
situation vu que
considérer que la maladie est liée à une
exposition professionnelle ça peut être
compliqué surtout sur les pesticides
l'exposition en pesticides et donc il
était
plus intéressant et c'est une
amélioration d'avoir une seule et unique
commission qui se spécialisée quelque
part dans l'exposition au pesticides et
le lien avec la maladie professionnelle
également pour vous indiquer que ce fond
pesticides donc voilà le cancer le
tableau de ma vie professionnelle cancer
de la proscate prostate pardon s'inscrit
pleinement dans ce fond en fait c'est
il vient en fait conforter ce fond
s'inscrire dans ce fond et donc dans ce
fond le fond pesticide il a des
améliorations notables en matière de
reconnaissance de maladie
professionnelle donc avec une procédure
plus simple plus rapide et plus juste
donc notamment le fait d'avoir une
commission unique plutôt que d'avoir
plusieurs commissions régionales est une
amélioration il a des améliorations
aussi en termes de d'indemnisation alors
c'est uniquement pour les enfin c'est
uniquement pour les non salariés
agricoles avec un niveau d'indemnisation
qui est plus important que pour une
autre maladie professionnelle qui n'est
pas liée aux pesticides pourquoi parce
que on s'est aperçu alors on peut pas
comparer exactement les niveaux
d'indemnisation mais globalement les
niveaux d'indemnisation des non salariés
agricoles donc des exploitants agricoles
des indépendants étaient
un peu moins bien que pour les salariés
agricoles donc on va venir compléter
l'indemnisation donc à l'indemnisation
de base comme toute ATMP indemnisation
ATMP et puis on vient la compléter pour
la mettre au niveau de celle des
salariés troisième amélioration en plus
du meilleur organisation et une
simplification des procédures c'est
qu'on élargit aussi le panel des
personnes qui sont susceptibles de
bénéficier d'une organisation au-delà
des salariés et des non salariés
agricoles on va venir aussi donner une
capacité à indemniser les retraités
agricoles avant 2002 pourquoi avant 2002
c'est parce que
les retraités les retraités avant 2002
parce que je en fait pour les
exploitants agricoles il y a donc c'est
une spécificité c'est une spécificité
pour les indépendants c'est la seule
profession indépendante qui a un régime
d'action du travail de mardi
professionnelle il y en a pas d'autres
il y a que des régimes volontaires mais
là c'est obligatoire mais ça a été
instauré en 2002 donc comme le font
s'appuie sur les régimes ATMP les
personnes qui sont partis à la retraite
avant 2002 n'ont pas cotisé un régime
ATMP donc ne sont pas éligibles donc là
avec le fond on vient les rattraper pour
les maladies professionnelles en lien
avec les pesticides et ensuite on vient
aussi permettre à l'indemnisation des
enfants qui sont exposés inuttéraux
du fait de l'exposition de leur parent
mais d'une exposition professionnelle de
leurs parents donc on élargit aussi la
population éligible à une indemnisation
en termes de modalités d'indemnisation
donc là j'en ai parlé on a un tableau si
vous voulez qu'on pourra vous passer
pour bien expliquer quels sont les
niveaux d'indemnisation
on l'indemnisation diffère en fonction
de l'incapacité à ce qu'elle est
temporaire à ce qu'elle est permanente
donc c'est soit les indemnités
journalières soit des rentes ou des
capitaux mais en tout cas qui sont plus
importants que si on est dans un régime
classique d'ATP et puis donc
l'analysation des enfants c'est une
spécificité donc là on a on a dû créer
un barème forfaitaire spécifique donc
c'est l'arrêté du 7 janvier 2002 qui
fixe les règles de réparation
forfaitaire et c'est le conseil de
gestion du fond pesticides qui a planché
pour proposer ça a été son premier
travail une fois qu'il a été créé en
2020 c'est de créer ce barème qui
mentionne 5 pathologies la leucémie de
la tumeur cérébrale la fente la
biopalatine
lipospadias et les troubles du
neurodéveloppement mais
si un enfant souffre d'une autre
pathologie et qui considère que c'est
lié à l'exposition de ses parents il
peut quand même déposer un dossier il
sera examiné
enfin terminé par quelques chiffres
donc sur le nombre de victimes
professionnelles donc les
si on regarde le depuis que le fond est
créé au 1er janvier 2020 on a le fond
pesticides on a une augmentation
du nombre de dossiers qui sont déposés
depuis 2020 donc on est en 2020 on était
à 226 dossiers aujourd'hui en 2022 au 30
septembre on était à 468 donc une
augmentation au total depuis le 1er
janvier 2020 on a donc 1020 dossiers qui
ont été déposés et on a déjà 642 accords
donc après il y a des dossiers qui sont
encore en cours de traitement mais
globalement on a entre
70 et 80% d'accord donc de
reconnaissance
depuis la création du fond sur les
demandes qui sont déposées il faut avoir
en tête que les maladies
professionnelles alors je prends juste
les données du régime agricole parce
qu'une des spécificités de ce fond c'est
qu'il est aussi valable pour les
professions qui sont hors agricoles par
exemple le fabricant de pesticides
aussi bénéficier du fond et là ils sont
dans le régime général donc là je reste
dans le régime agricole
on a les maladies professionnelles qui
sont liées aux
pesticides représentent en 2021 4% de
toutes les maladies professionnelles qui
sont reconnues
sur la décennie 2010-2019 c'était 0,4 %.
donc on a une forte augmentation
mais c'est pas les principales manies
professionnelles les principales
maladies professionnelles qui sont
reconnues c'est les troubles
musculoosquelettiques de très très loin
c'est plus de 90% je crois
quelques données sur le cancer de la
prostate pour finir donc avant la
création du fond donc avant le 1er
janvier 2020 on avait 10 demandes ou des
accords
professionnelles aussi du cancer de la
prostate entre le 1er janvier 2020 et la
création du tableau donc en deux ans
globalement deux ans on a eu 18 demandes
depuis le 22 décembre 2021 donc depuis
un an on a 207 demandes donc on voit
qu'effectivement la création du tableau
est un outil qui permet en fait
d'améliorer la reconnaissance en maladie
professionnelle pour les enfants donc là
c'est une procédure un peu nouvelle on a
9 demandes qui ont été déposées
aujourd'hui
peut-être pour affiner un peu les
demandes sur les 207 demandes depuis la
création du tableau on a 150 accords
dont 14 pour les Antilles voilà ça c'est
lié au fait que voilà c'est un tableau
qui ne concerne pas que les Antilles
c'est lié à l'exposition des pesticides
de manière générale et donc du coup on a
évidemment des dossiers aux Antilles qui
sont pour le coup probablement liés à la
chlore bacon mais on a aussi des
dossiers en métropole et dans les autres
territoires ultramarins voilà ce que je
pouvais vous dire sur ce sujet
bien merci beaucoup à tous les trois on
va passer à la partie question alors je
vais me permettre de commencer la
question sauf si Pierre tu veux alors
moi c'est des questions très très
matériel et très concrète alors déjà
professeur Multinet vous ne savez parler
beaucoup de souris alors est-ce que
quand on n'est pas des spécialistes je
sais bien qu'on travaille beaucoup sur
les souris mais est-ce que le modèle des
souris permet forcément de d'avoir des
projections exactes sur l'homme et une
question aussi trois générations de
souris
est-ce que ça correspond à 3 générations
d'hommes de femmes de femmes ou d'hommes
parce que bon la souris elle dure je ne
sais pas quelle est sa durée de vie mais
elle est pas de maintenant elle est pas
de 75 ou de 80 ans c'est alors j'ai
peut-être poser les trois questions
tu me viennent à l'esprit avant de
passer un temps à mes collègues et pour
répondre
[Musique]
on a beaucoup enfin on a parlé des
Antilles
mais j'aimerais que l'on puisse vous
avez évoqué enfin je sais que vous avez
écrit que quand on est plus exposé
c'est-à-dire quand on vit plus aux
Antilles on a plus le facteur
d'exposition puisque l'accordéon il y en
a pas eu enfin il y en a eu ailleurs
dans les pays de l'Est mais on va pas
forcément dans les pays d'est est-ce que
dans ces cas là on a pu mesurer
compte tenu de la durée de vie de la
chlore des cônes
si les personnes qui avaient été aux
Antilles ont autant de risques enfin un
facteur aggravant de risque qu'on est
emmené aux Antilles même si après ils
ont fait carrière ou vécu en outre-mer
est-ce qu'on peut s'en rendre compte
vous m'avez madame
santé publique France a parlé de 5% qui
ont un taux d'imprégnation mais est-ce
que ce taux c'est purement
population qui vivent aux Antilles ou
est-ce que c'est toutes les populations
d'origine
antillaise et puis la troisième question
alors là qui me dépasse enfin c'est les
indemnisations des enfants ils
uteraux vous avez parlé de d'un certain
nombre de cancers y compris des termes
médicaux des maladies que je ne sais pas
identifier mais
comment peut-on lier ça puisque les
études qui ont été faites jusqu'à
présent sur la chlordécone
prouve les facteurs de risque
supplémentaires mais on n'a pas est-ce
qu'il y a eu des études
qui prouve que la chlordécone et où les
pesticides
sont à l'origine d'autres maladies c'est
c'est le côté enfant qui me fait poser
cette question
moi je si vous voulez bien chers
collègues je demande une réponse et puis
je vous pose sa parole et on passe la
parole aux internautes
je reviens sur les souris j'ai fait
exprès tout en sachant que ce sont des
domaines d'expérience qui sont pas en
lien en tant que
par rapport à mon activité
d'épidémiologiste ce que j'ai voulu
souligner par là c'est que
les expositions des populations ce sont
des études qui ont été faites la plupart
des mises en place sur la période 2004
2007 c'est-à-dire qui précède finalement
les grandes mesures de gestion du risque
et notamment avec les arrêtés
préfectoraux enfin toute une série de
mesures qui ont fait que effectivement
les niveaux d'exposition ont dépassé
donc je parle effectivement de ces
risques là qu'on pourrait même
quantifier et qu'on puisse subir donc
les populations
liées à la pollution des milieux
naturels depuis la fin des années au
milieu des années 1970
il ne faut pas comment dire
se reposer sur les lauriers en disant
voilà on met en place des mesures les
niveaux d'exposition diminue c'est bien
mais
ces mesures de gestion de prévention et
de réduction d'exposition tenant compte
du fait que le
bassin où se trouve le chlore des cône
c'est à dire les sols les sols à partir
de quel il y a la contamination des
milieux bah lui il va perdurer pardon
beaucoup d'années non c'est pas des
décennies des siècles mais enfin un
certain temps autrement dit les mesures
de prévention de réduction des risques
c'est bien aujourd'hui mais il va
falloir continuer à les
développer les maintenir pendant des
dizaines d'années
la question de la souris au-delà de la
connaissance sur les effets
transgénérationnels
je vous réponds oui on peut faire un
équivalent du processus de la gestation
et des processus biologiques
fondamentaux c'est la souris et chez
l'homme pour ça il y a un partage même
si on n'est pas une antique mais c'est
montrer surtout que c'était
des souris qui ont été exposés à des
doses relativement faibles donc c'est
énorme de montrer que il peut y avoir il
pourrait y avoir on n'a pas la preuve
mais en tout cas ça suggère la
possibilité donc de risque à venir si on
ne protège pas en particulier les
populations les plus sensibles
c'est-à-dire la femme enceinte
à cet égard
déjà aux Antilles il y a les ARS mettre
en place des actions de prévention vers
ces populations cibles voilà moi c'était
un peu pour illustrer uniquement ce
aspect là
je voudrais répondre à une toute petite
question qui vous a été adressée parce
que je pense que je veux je vous
faciliterai la tâche certes dans le cas
du chlordécone
on observe un certain nombre d'effets
mais qui sont visiblement quantifiables
en tant que maladie proprement dite mais
ce qui est couvert par le fondanisation
des victimes des pesticides c'est c'est
toutes les atteintes qui sont suspectés
connues au regard de l'ensemble des
divers pesticides et là ce n'est pas le
chlore bacon certes mais on peut penser
par exemple il y a beaucoup de questions
sur la survenue de cancer chez l'enfant
oui ce sont des questions entre
l'exposition de pesticides donc il y a
plein de de pathologies sachant que
chaque molécule si vous voulez chaque
pesticide a sa propre son propre profil
toxicologique
et pour compléter aussi un élément y
compris au niveau des Antilles certes le
chlore déconne a été un aiguillon pour
tout ce processus mais il faut bien
savoir que déjà en 2013 l'expertise
collective de l'Inserm
soulignait
les risques associés entre l'exposition
aux pesticides de façon générale en
particulier en milieu professionnel et
l'excès de risque
de survenue du cancer de la prostate
observé en Europe en Amérique du Nord
dans tous les continents sans qu'on
puisse mettre non et prénom sur la
molécule le cas du clan des corn c'est
un cas d'espèces dans lequel on peut le
désigner mais il y a tous les autres
donc ce que donc vous avez parlé vous
avez bien fait d'assister sur ces
concombres tous les pesticides et je
pense que ça c'est très important pour
les Antilles parce que certes il y a eu
peur déconne mais les agriculteurs les
travailleurs agriculteurs de la banane y
compris dans la période 70 et 4 et 80 ne
se sont pas uniquement utilisés que le
chlordécone il y a eu énormément
d'autres catégories de pesticides et en
plus à des doses relativement massives
tenant compte des conditions climatiques
qui favorisent bien sûr les nuisances
donc
chlordécone ou pas que leur déconne
c'est un bon dispositif pour la
population en général et y compris pour
les personnes qui ont été exposées aux
pesticides professionnellement aux
Antilles on ne sait toujours
la différence c'est que la couleur des
cône ne disparaît pas peut-être aussi
facilement que d'autres pesticides pour
la chlordécone je préciserai ce point là
certes enfin dans notre organisme il
faut à peu près enfin c'est maintenant
puisqu'en plus on a publié récemment ce
qu'on appelle un modèle
pharmacocinétique du chlore bacon chez
l'homme
il faut que la moitié disparaisse de
notre corps il faut à peu près 5 mois
pour faire simple ce qui fait que
98% de ce que nous pouvons avoir à un
moment donné va disparaître au terme de
2 à 3 ans une variabilité à condition
qu'on consomme plus de
alors effectivement quelqu'un qui a vécu
aux Antilles
je vais citer mon casier est vécu
pendant 8 ans bon et puis je suis revenu
en métropole peut-être que pendant les
huit ans j'ai été exposé ça va faire
maintenant 5 ans que je suis rentré
même si j'exploité j'ai plus de traces
de chlore déconnes pour autant ça
n'empêche pas que si j'ai été exposé
pendant X années ça puisse
éventuellement contribuer à
un effet vous voyez sur la sur la santé
mais tout ce qui s'est dit sur le
déconne on part de l'idée que c'est une
population qui réside bien sûr on a tous
les cas d'espèces il y a le touriste qui
vient il y a le l'Antillais qui
part en métropole pendant un certain
nombre d'années puis qui qui reviennent
mais voilà il faut
oui je voulais juste revenir sur votre
question puis peut-être précisé pour les
les 5% que vous avez mentionné en fait
donc dans l'enquête canari c'est une
enquête transversale ce qui fait un
moment donné c'est-à-dire que ce sont
les personnes qui sont sur le territoire
à un moment donné il se trouve que ce
qui était il y a une notion de de durée
c'est à comprendre des personnes qui
sont là depuis un certain temps qui sont
majeurs et on regarde qu'il soit là
encore un petit peu quelque temps pour
qu'on puisse les inclure et avoir des
dosages donc on est vraiment sur cette
notion de de Tan statique de personnes
présents à un temps donné sur sur le
territoire les 5% ça correspond pas à
des gens qui ont une valeur au-dessus de
la valeur qui définir un impact
sanitaire c'est simplement que dans la
variabilité des résultats
les 5% sont ceux qui sont dix fois plus
exposés que la moyenne c'est comme ça
qu'on avait identifié cette population
de personnes qui avaient des valeurs
très élevées la proportion de personnes
qui seront au-dessus de la valeur
toxicologique de référence interne elle
sera présentée en décembre effectivement
je voilà on a on a beaucoup de choses
qui sont qui sont attendues et
en fonction de en fonction du seuil qui
a été déterminé dans dans le dans les
travaux de l'ancêtre et c'est vraiment
le la population qui qui pour laquelle
on aura aussi vraiment à définir des
politiques enfin des politiques
publiques qui s'adaptent vraiment adapté
à cette exposition élevée et qui
permettront de pouvoir vraiment cibler
cette action en fonction des
caractéristiques qui seront identifiés
merci peut-être effectivement pour
compléter la réponse sur les enfants
donc en fait on sait bêtement je dirais
basé sur les dernières connaissances
scientifiques et notamment dans le dans
le rapport de lances de l'Inserm pardon
de 2021 il était mentionné pour les
pathologies de l'enfant avec une
présentation forte de lien avec
l'exposition pesticides l'altération des
capacités motrices cognitives et
sensorielle le trouble du comportement
en particulier du type internalisé des
teammeurs de système nerveux central et
les leucémies et donc c'est assez
naturellement que ces maladies ont été
reprises dans l’arrêté
comme des maladies qui permettent la
reconnaissance plus facile après comme
je disais si on n'est pas dans ces
maladies mais que on arrive à démontrer
qu'il y a la maladie a été liée à
l'exposition de ses parents
on peut quand même prétendre à une
indemnisation si c'est démontré mais
avec ces maladies voilà le lien de
présomption est déjà plus plus
simplement établi peut-être aussi pour
indiquer qu'effectivement
une fois qu'on a la déclenchement de la
maladie et qu'on a l'exposition
c'est toute la difficulté des tableaux
de ma vie professionnelle comme il crée
une présomption d'imputabilité quand on
respecte les critères du tableau on a la
reconnaissance automatique le la
définition des critères et vraiment un
sujet là qui qui est compliqué il faut
trouver un bon équilibre pour
effectivement mais je pense que vous
l'avez vous l'avez bien indiqué on peut
être enfin souffrir d'une maladie qui
est pas forcément liée à l'exposition
professionnelle donc il faut que les
critères du tableau soit bien positionné
pour que on englobe la maladie liée à
l'exposition professionnelle
excusez-moi je vous passe la parole me
chers collègues mais c'est quand on a
travail donc les travailleurs des
bananerait parce qu'on peut supposer
aussi puisque on sait bien que le nombre
de bananerais a disparu
et moins important qu'il y a 30 ou 40
ans on peut avoir cultivé des produits
des plans tracés sur des terres de
bananerer par exemple et est-ce que ces
travailleurs-là sont concernés oui bah à
partir du moment où il démontre
l'exposition dans un une exposition
pendant 10 ans sur une terre qui est
polluée enfin voilà après on rentre
effectivement dans l'examen au cas par
cas où il faut qu'on arrive
effectivement à démontrer que le travail
pendant enfin sur cette terre là expose
à la aux pesticides et en l'occurrence à
la clandécone si on s'intéresse à cette
maladie
on peut très bien reconvertir un seul
pollué de bananeraie de le faire
cultiver ça a été ce qui a été décrit
d'ailleurs par ce mégaroff en déjà on
dit 1977 des aubergines
et puis traiter les aubergines comment
les traite par des pesticides à ce
moment-là vous êtes exposés aux
pesticides quand bien même ce n'est pas
l'accord des godes en plus du fait que
le chlordécone a été éventuellement dans
le sol mais bon on ne plonge pas dans le
sol on applique des pesticides mais donc
là on fait pas de distinction dans les
procédures
merci beaucoup et je m'excuse d'avance
pour mes collègues comme j'ai été élu en
juin je n'ai pas assisté à la première
réunion donc je vais peut-être poser des
questions dont vous avez déjà les
réponses
[Musique]
donc voilà j'avais une question donc
j'ai bien compris que les intoxications
continuaient aujourd'hui
et ce par l'alimentation notamment et la
proximité avec des zones où il y a eu
l'utilisation de ce produit
j'ai lu dans des articles donc j'ai à
peu près cette audition que la demi-vie
de la chlordécone dans l'environnement
était évalué à 250 et 650 ans dans les
sols
moi j'ai une question simple c'est
est-ce que on a des prévisions sur quand
cela ne sera plus un problème parce que
j'ai l'impression que les sols sont
condamnés ou est-ce qu'il y a un
traitement pour réhabiliter ces sols car
de mon point de vue je vois pas vraiment
d'autres solutions pour pour mettre fin
à
ce problème et donc là on a beaucoup
parlé aujourd'hui de comment traiter les
conséquences donc avec les aides que
l'on propose les accompagnements mais
est-ce que
vous êtes penché sur comment traiter les
causes donc notamment sur la
réhabilitation des sols vous avez parlé
de changer par exemple les
recommandations alimentaires la manière
de s'alimenter
je comprends qu'il y a des réticences
parce qu'il y a un certain mode de vie
et ça touche comme vous l'avez dit à la
tradition
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire quelle
recommandation alimentaire ont été
faites pour qu'on puisse peut-être
comprendre aussi pourquoi ces tiré et ça
sera déjà bien merci
simplement faire un premier résumé
rapide
nous avons eu entre guillemets le
plaisir de découvrir que la recherche
avait quand même un peu progressé alors
là tant déconne est une molécule très
particulière complètement engagée et
qu'on n'arrive pas qu'on n'arrive pas à
démolir à casser soit naturellement
comme beaucoup de pesticides soit
par d'autres systèmes et que la chlore
des codes reste dans le sol ça dépend
aussi du type de sol et dans les soldes
qui sont
les sols en volcaniques c'est encore
plus compliqué mais à des scientifiques
donc de la première plate de la première
table ronde nous semble dire que ce ne
serait plus comme il y a 10 ans 350 à
700 ans mais seulement je dis bien entre
guillemets seulement une centaine
d'années
le problème et que pour l'instant il n'y
a pas de solutions scientifiques à la
dépollution des sols il y a des
recherches et les recherches sont quand
même un peu avancées
depuis depuis 10 ans des recherches qui
font que il y a une possibilité
non pas de dépolluer tous les sols de
Martinique et de Guadeloupe mais de
réussir à atténuer la pollution des sols
ça coûte très cher je me souviens plus
les montants mais ça coûte très cher
mais en même temps la vie des hommes
quel est le prix aussi d'après
toutes ces recherches sont des
recherches de l'amour
on a les
scientifiques nous ont dit
qu'effectivement il y avait un peu moins
de il y avait quelques molécules de
chlorecones qu'on pouvait voir des
truites naturellement mais pour
l'instant on en est encore à cette phase
de recherche et alors pour vous résumer
et pour dans l'étude que nous allions en
fait en 2009 on s'était dit que c'était
pas possible que la chlordécone qui
n'était plus produite officiellement aux
États-Unis puisqu'il a produisait en
douce au Brésil ne la produisent que
pour un petit territoire celui des
bananerets des Antilles on a
effectivement découverts contre les
tonnes qui étaient produites au Brésil
ce qu'on utilisait aux Antilles et on
avait on utilisait 10 ou 20%. tout le
reste est allé pour lutter contre le
doryphore à l'époque dans tout ce qui
était les pays de l'Est Allemagne de
l'Est Pologne etc et j'avais le seul
objectif de l'Opel c'est un objectif
scientifique nous avions été jusqu'au
parlement européen et nous avions été en
Allemagne parce qu'il y avait l'extrait
de l'Est en espérant une coopération
scientifique il n'est pas question pour
nous à l'OPEX de dire la responsabilité
dix ou dynque mais la responsabilité des
scientifiques c'est aboutir et bien
aucun des autres pays qui ont utilisé le
champ des connes n'a voulu
reconnaître l'existence du chlore des
cônes dans les sols et donc la recherche
scientifique ne repose que sur les
équipes françaises c'est un vrai souci
alors là je n'ai répondu que par rapport
à la première table ronde
peut-être juste par rapport juste un
micro complément par rapport à ce qui
vient d'être dit sur le justement
l'accompagnement des populations et le
programme Jafa par exemple qu'on a
accompagne et qu'on les jardins
familiaux on accompagne et qu'on va
évaluer c'est des techniques de culture
pour limiter justement le la le contact
avec avec les sols qui peuvent être
contaminés pour les recommandations
alimentaires je vais laisser mon
collègue jacrosine qui est responsable
de la cellule anti vous répondre qui
vous répondra plus précisément que moi
qui est à distance
[Musique]
on vous on ne vous voit pas mais on vous
entend donc si vous pouvez intervenir
[Musique]
vous pourriez vous rapprocher du micro
et un petit bruit de fond pour qu'on
vous entende mieux
moyennement
oui c'est un peu mieux
[Musique]
donc en termes de recommandations ce qui
a été fait en lien avec les équipes de
lancias c'est vraiment de dire que pour
certains produits notamment les produits
par son pays les poissons
qui sont déchets dans les zones
contaminées donc on sera pas alignements
de la diminution de la fréquence de
consommation de ces produits
de deux ou trois fois par semaine par
exemple pour limiter la contamination
qui est donc
respecter les valeurs de psychologie de
[Musique]
référence
merci
enfin on a à peu près entendu
madame madame Bénin on vous donne la
parole vous vouliez intervenir
est-ce qu'on peut voir Madame Bénin
madame Benard est-ce que vous nous
entendez est-ce que vous pouvez ouvrir
votre micro
non ça ne ressemble pas Madame Ménard
voilà
bonjour on vous voit merci non c'est pas
vous
non
l'association vive oui alors attendez
vous êtes sur la deuxième table ronde là
je voudrais déjà qu'on pose les
questions et mes collègues présents
alors en attendant l'intervention madame
alors qui pose une question Angèle
Préville
si madame la Présidente alors donc moi
je voulais d'abord demander puisque vous
avez évoqué je vais droit au but jusqu'à
la troisième génération ça veut dire que
nous aussi
au niveau des
êtres humains on va devoir surveiller
sur plusieurs générations ou pas et
ensuite vous avez pas mal mentionné les
cancers qui sont liés au travailleur
est-ce que parce que comme on a parlé de
perturbation endocrinienne est-ce qu'on
peut penser qu'il y aura aussi des
cancers disons plus féminins qui vont se
développer par la suite et donc
peut-être un suivi ou pas qui sera fait
sur ces cancers notamment je pense au
cancer du sein ensuite sur les les parce
qu'on peut parler de cocktail du coup de
pesticides ce que je suis quand même
impressionnée par le nombre de
pesticides qui a été employé en
Guadeloupe et en Martinique et les
effets cocktails qui sont à étudier qui
sont très difficiles à étudier avec
peut-être la couleur des cônes qui
un des pesticides qui qui va être le
plus
et alors moi je pense à ça aussi le
chlore des cônes donc ne réagit pas
beaucoup et reste assez stable est-ce
que
avec les autres tous les autres
pesticides qui ont été utilisés est-ce
qu'il y a déjà ce qu'on sait déjà s'il y
a eu des réactions chimiques possibles
avec des métabolites qui se réformés et
qui serait plutôt que si ou pas après
j'ai une autre question sur en
population générale donc une grande
variabilité sur comme vous dites
l'imprégnation qui est une contamination
en fait est-ce que on a déjà
identifié les facteurs qui feraient que
certaines populations
seraient plus impactée que d'autres par
rapport à cette imprégnation et c'est
tout voilà parce que la question sur les
jardins familiaux a déjà été
j'ai une question pour vous professeur
multinier quand vous avez évoqué
l'infertilité masculine la Bretonne que
je suis ça lui parle puisque c'est vrai
qu'on a un taux surélevé de cas
d'infertilité masculine et également de
10 ovulation chez la femme donc c'était
une question est-ce que ces données qui
date de plusieurs années en Bretagne sur
le rapport entre pesticides et
infertilité masculine vous pensez à un
moment les croiser vous rapprocher des
auteurs de ces études et puis
vous avez dit également professeur que
concernant les femmes il y avait pas de
données mais vous avez évoqué des
perspectives à venir et est-ce qu'on
peut en savoir un peu plus vers quel
sujet vous allez quel rapport par
rapport aux pesticides merci et victoire
jasmin merci beaucoup
je voudrais justement revenir parce que
vous avez par les décontaminations alors
direct par rapport aux personnes qui ont
été les utilisateurs il y a eu aussi des
contaminations indirectes par les
personnes qui vivent sur ces terres-là
mais il y avait aussi l'épandage aérien
et on ne parle pas tellement de cela et
c'était des aérosols pour certaines
personnes donc je pense que beaucoup
beaucoup de personnes ont été également
victimes de cette épandage aérien ce qui
n'est pas forcément fonctionné et
concernant la durée de vie sur dans les
sols la molécule de chlorure donc on
voit très bien que chaque fois qu'il des
inondations il y a quand même dans la
mer ça continue à exister ça va exister
pendant longtemps bon vous avez donné à
peu près les durées de vie mais c'est
une molécule qui ne se dissout pas si
elle était possible qu'elle se dit seul
avec toutes les autres nous avons eu et
bon c'est un sujet et bien elle continue
à exister et à résister également dans
les sols donc et la dernière la dernière
chose concernant vous avez évoqué et la
l'étude Jafa c'est vrai que les sols ne
sont pas utilisables d'une époque quelle
manière mais avec les travaux de l'ILEPS
notamment dans les différents programmes
il y a des conseils à la fois pour les
gens des familiaux mais aussi avec la
Chambre d'Agriculture et avec un certain
nombre de d'autres professionnels il y a
quand même des
usages possibles mais je crois qu'il va
falloir quand même utiliser et évaluer
la portée de ces usages mais il y a des
effectivement des cultures qui sont
adaptables parce qu'elles ne sont pas
dans le sol et cela c'est ce que tu
disais donc il va falloir évidemment
évaluer tout cela sur sur le moyen et le
long terme
la question le président de lepex
j'avais une question particulièrement
pour Monsieur Cunin vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure notamment la situation des
ouvriers agricoles notamment donc leur
prise en charge
et dans notamment dans la reconnaissance
de la maladie professionnelle qu'en
est-il également pour tous ces
travailleurs qui ont été sans
déclaration de contrat de travail au
niveau social aussi je suppose que la la
la demande et la mobilisation doit être
assez forte et puis on a également une
question de d'un
auditeur sur vous évoquez tout à l'heure
le facteur 10
de maladies professionnelles liées aux
pesticides
donc une augmentation assez
significative entre 2000 entre 2010-2019
et 2021 de 4%, est-ce que c'est lié à
une nouvelle méthodologie est-ce que
voilà si vous pouvez nous aussi nous
nous préciser notamment la la part de la
chlordécone dans ce dans cette prise en
compte
alors
professeur Multinet je me sens visé par
pas mal donc j'ai essayé de noter je
vais voilà donc je vais je parle bon là
encore je regrette presque de vous avoir
parlé du souris excusez-moi
non c'est
je suis c'était pas pour dire oui oui on
va craindre une hécatombe
c'est de dire voilà il y a une
possibilité qui existe qui est observée
chez l'animal ben voilà et elle peut
exister peut-être tenant compte des
niveaux d'exposition la population et ça
en tout cas ça doit commander
ça n'empêche pas de toute façon de faire
la surveillance des maladies comme on
les fait habituellement mais de se
donner encore un argument supplémentaire
pour les politiques de réduction des
expositions
voilà pour dire voilà ce qui est en jeu
c'est pas simplement nous aujourd'hui
mais c'est aussi ce que nous pouvons
éventuellement transmettre comme risque
supplémentaire à nos enfants voilà c'est
c'était un peu plus dans ce dans cet
esprit et puis pour vous livrer aussi
que la que la recherche continue pour en
savoir plus même si c'est un peu loin
peut-être de l'application
pragmatique vous avez prononcé cancer
chez des travailleurs je voudrais vous
préciser que les travaux qui ont été
réalisés sur le cancer de la prostate
aux Antilles s'adresse à la population
générale donc c'est un seul risque de la
population générale certes les
travailleurs ont été potentiellement
plus exposés mais je voudrais quand même
vous faire part des données que nous
avions obtenu dès la fin des années 90
ont été transmis d'ailleurs à l'âme 16
au moment où ils ont fait ce rapport sur
lequel vous vous êtes appuyé c'est que
ce que nous avions constaté en mesurant
le chlore des codes dans le sang fin des
années 90
euh c'est qu'effectivement les
travailleurs agricoles de la banane
présentaient un peu plus de chlordécone
on sent que le reste de la population
mais c'était Carla n'était pas aussi
important que celui qu'on pourrait faire
pour un pesticide X ou Y en France
métropolitaine entre un agriculteur et
quelqu'un qui habite dans une ville dans
lequel certes il va être contaminé par
des pesticides mais plus ça l'état de
trace donc vous voyez c'est ce delta
entre population des travailleurs qui
ont été effectivement les plus concernés
mais c'est quand même la population
générale voilà c'est pas uniquement
cette catégorie alors certes pour un
concours toute une série de de raisons
nous nous sommes intéressés au cancer de
la prostate et nous avons un peu plus
difficultés à ce jour à nous intéresser
au cancer du sein pour toute une série
de de raison strictement logistique ce
sont des maladies voilà le système de
prise en charge est multiple il y a
enfin X raisons sur lequel je ne peux
pas détailler ça fait partie
de des réflexions que nous avons
actuellement j'ai eu l'occasion d'en
parler avec la Direction générale de la
santé pour qu'on puisse peut-être mettre
en place une des études de faisabilité
voilà en tout cas c'est une question
posée après tout le corps et à des
propriétaires hormonales et pourquoi pas
voilà
la question la question des hélicoptères
alors c'est une question sur laquelle on
n'a pas de réponse simple face à la
Myria de substance chimique donc c'est
inutile de par contre dans les études
que je vous ai montré nous n'avons pas
me doser que le chlore bacon c'est le
DDE des PCB d'autres polluants et nos
résultats prennent en compte ces effets
multiples donc ça je voudrais vous voilà
en termes de réaction chimique vous
savez la molécule chlore des cannes à
une particule hérité c'est que elle est
incapable de réagir avec qui que ce soit
puisque c'est une structure absolument
il y a une petite fonction s'étonne qui
est un petit peu métabolisée dans
l'organisme humain mais vous voyez c'est
c'est un
[Musique]
c'est une architecture de Vauban vous
voyez c'est voilà c'est inattaquable
donc je vois le mal réagir avec d'autres
voilà
oui on a parlé d'infertilité masculine
et de la Bretagne ça tombe bien vous
savez que je notre institut de recherche
est basérel moi-même mon domaine de
spécialité depuis 25 ans c'est la
fertilité masculine je peux vous
rassurer la Bretagne n'est pas pire
qu'ailleurs
si vous voulez voilà je suis situé à
Rennes je pourrais vous en parler en
leur à l'âge intérieur même si c'est une
préoccupation voilà mais il y a pas de
de voilà de particularité bretonne je
dirais pas plus
qu'ailleurs
le chlore déconne n'a jamais ça c'est il
faut tordre cette fausse idée n'a jamais
jamais été appliqué par épandage aérien
le chlore déconne ça a toujours été une
poudre à la main beaucoup de femmes
étaient
étaient à la tâche de de l'épandage
parce que c'était une tâche un peu plus
légère que celle de porter un régime de
banane de 60 kg mais par contre il y a
eu deux dépendage aérien jusqu'à il y a
pas très longtemps mais ce sont d'autres
pesticides de type fongicides pour
traiter la cercosporiose ou la feuille
de oui enfin les feuilles de bananier
qui deviennent jaunes et qui tout mais
en tout cas le chlore bacon ça je peux
vous assurer
c'est c'est pas pareil pendant j'ai rien
même si celui-ci en utilisant d'autres
produits à eux probablement d'autres
effets et puis par rapport à ce que oui
du devenir de chlore déconne le
réservoir c'est le sol
en gros les premiers maîtres s'il ne
pleuvait pas aux Antilles tu serais
quand même assez surprenant
mais c'est à cause de la pluie il pleut
beaucoup
par un effet de percolation comme la
machine à café ou de ruissellement que
tout ça va se retrouver dans les nappes
phréatiques supérieures les rivières
profondes d'ailleurs certaines zones de
source bien connues de ces deux Basters
sont
traitées à charbon pour être
commercialisé vous le savez donc ce sont
quand même des sources profondes et tout
cela finit bien entendu sur les côtes
dans laquelle ça va contaminer
la difficulté c'est que
on estimait jusqu'à maintenant qu'un bon
tiers des surfaces agricoles utiles et
un bon tiers des littoraux marins de la
Guadeloupe et de la Martinique sont
contaminés j'ai lu dans le dernier
rapport que vient de publier l'inrae sur
pesticides et environnement voilà j'ai
vu des chiffres jusqu'à 50 %, ça
pourrait aller donc ce sont des dizaines
de milliers d'hectares
et on ne dépollue pas ça quelle que soit
les solutions que j'espère que la
recherche va apporter c'est pas la même
chose de dépolluer un site pollué autour
de l'usine que des dizaines de milliers
d'hectares donc voilà je bon je pense
que j'ai
oublié quelque chose vous me le dites
alors merci bah écoutez pour répondre
aux questions enfin pour rebondir sur
l'effet cocktail je pense qu'on a
insisté là-dessus en ce qui concerne la
maladie professionnelle comme on a
l'exposition pesticides de fait on
intègre l'effet cocktail donc il y a pas
en quelque part ce facteur n'intervient
pas
pour répondre aux questions du président
donc sur les déclarations alors on est
vraiment dans le cadre d'une exposition
professionnelle c'est un sujet qui avait
vraiment fait des balles de la création
du fondalisation légitime de pesticides
compte tenu des connaissances
scientifiques on se place dans le cadre
de l'exposition professionnelle donc il
faut réussir à démontrer qu'on a bien
une exposition professionnelle pour
bénéficier de cette
indemnisation
et donc de fait quand on a des gens qui
ne sont pas déclarés c'est très
compliqué de pouvoir bénéficier de cette
indemnisation voir impossible donc ce
qu'on regarde c'est effectivement la
personne quand elle est salarié elle a
bien été affilié au régime
donc pas forcément le cotisation ont été
payées etc on regarde que elle a été
affiliée si elle n'a pas été c'est
extrêmement compliqué voire impossible
de bénéficier de ce de ce régime là par
rapport au facteurs 10
de facteur 10 donc comment on l'explique
on l'explique par le fait que quelque
part la création des enfin une
explication parmi d'autres c'est que le
tableau de maladie professionnelle là on
a parlé du tableau 61 quand ça va
prostate mais j'ai indiqué que j'en
avais d'autres qui étaient vraiment liés
à l'exposition au pesticides le tableau
58 sur la maladie de Parkinson il date
de 2012 le tableau 59 sur les lymphomes
dont j'arrive pas à prononcer le nom nom
notre client voilà merci tu as de 2015
ils ont tous été revus en 2020 2019 pour
tenir compte des nouvelles des récentes
données scientifiques dont c'est des
tableaux quelque part assez récents et
c'est sans doute ça qui explique une
fois qu'on a les critères de tableau
comme on a une reconnaissance
automatique de fait c'est plus facile on
se pose enfin les on se pose pas la
question de savoir si c'est lié ou non
on remplit on rentre dans les cases du
tableau et donc du coup
on est la maladie professionnelle est
reconnue donc c'est ça qui doit
expliquer
principalement le fait que les maladies
professionnelles liées à l'exposition au
pesticides sont en augmentation même
s'il y a peut-être d'autres
raisons et peut-être préciser aussi que
quand on ne rentre pas dans le les
cadres du tableau donc il y a la
commission de reconnaissance de ma vie
professionnelle qui entre en jeu et
quand elle a les éléments sur le tableau
ça lui facilite aussi la chose pour
quand on ne respecte pas un critère
essayer de voir si quand même il peut y
avoir reconnaissance ma vie
professionnelle voilà ce que je pouvais
vous apporter comme comme précision en
réponse à ces questions
bien je vous remercie est-ce que
monsieur le Président
veut clôturer oui parce que pour on a
que 10 minutes très court pour répondre
à vos questions peut-être un peu de
façon synthétique où il y a des voix
apparaître des questions sur les enfants
et des questions sur les autres cancers
en particulier les cancers féminins pour
les enfants on a des dosages qui sont
prévus dans Canaries 2 qui étaient pas
présents dans Canaries mais qui seront
présents dans canari 2 et ce qui a été
aussi mis en place comme dispositif de
surveillance et qui est absolument
fondamental pour avoir justement une
approche populationnelle sur l'ensemble
des territoires de pouvoir avoir un
dispositif de surveillance performance
et un registre des malformations
congénitale qui a été mis en place en
2009 qui enregistre tous les cas de
malformations parmi les enfants
issus de grossesses de femmes résidentes
en Martinique et en Guadeloupe et dans
le rapport 2022 portant sur les données
2020 on ne retrouvait pas de sur
incidence de malformations congénitale
aux Antilles concernant les cancers il y
a un registre des cancers qui a été mis
en place à la Guadeloupe en 2008 qui
complète celui de la Martinique avec des
des activités de registres habituels et
deux volets de recherche spécifique qui
ont été définis un volet sur cancer et
facteurs environnementaux en Guadeloupe
et sciences humaines et sociales pour
leur autre axe de recherche dans les
incidences qui ont été rapportés
sur
sur les registres en comparaison des
résultats de la France hexagonale ce qui
peut se débattre on ne retrouve pas de
ce risque concernant les cancers du sein
on retrouve un sur-risque au niveau de
de
chez les femmes de myélome et de cancer
de l'utérus
et ça ça nécessite voilà ça nécessite
des travaux complémentaires qui sont en
cours notamment pour les myélomes avec
une un travail qui est sur les
myélomieux multiples et autres lymphomes
non match quinien dans les Antilles
françaises avec une évaluation des
expositions environnementales et
professionnelles aux pesticides sur la
Guadeloupe et la Martinique donc il
devrait apporter des éléments voilà
qu'on devrait pouvoir porter
prochainement
je vous remercie on va passer à la
seconde table ronde d'après une pause de
quelques minutes moi je voudrais
puisque
en tant que parlementaire je suis la
plus ancienne travailler à avoir
travaillé sur ce dossier dire que
il y a des progrès qui ont été faits
mais pas autant que lorsque avec
Jean-yves le néon nous avons
nous avions remis notre rapport alors si
je parle de la première table ronde
par exemple la carte on a découvert que
la cartographie des sols pollués n'était
pas terminé en 13 ans on aurait pu le
faire
et là surtout quand vous parlez
de des études qui ont été faits non pas
des études Canaries mais sur les jardins
familiaux et l'alimentation pour
répondre à notre collègue Alexandre
SABATOU
c'est quand même et vous avez parlé de
communication c'est quand même un échec
parce que en 2009 déjà Java Jafar était
lancé et on devait dire à la population
on disait à la population vous devez pas
manger de légumes racines si ces légumes
racines ont été cultivés dans des
jardins qui sont pollués vous devez
faire attention à population à la
consommation et là vous nous dites
qu'on
peut grosso modo il faut faire une
campagne d'information ça veut dire que
quand même ce qui a été fait depuis
une dizaine d'années alors je veux pas
être méchante et dire que c'est un échec
mais n'a pas produit les fruits puisque
là on se relance dans grosso modo les
mêmes informations donc
nouvelle campagne d'information c'est
pourquoi ça n'a pas fonctionné aux
Antilles puisque ce qui avait été décidé
à l'époque
c'était qu'effectivement la population
ne mange pas en étant exposé en ne
mangeant que trois fois par semaine
par exemple des légumes en racines ça
devait diminuer l'exposition et pas
augmenter d'autres maladies comme le
diabète en mangeant n'importe quoi et de
la et de l'alimentation
complètement transformé donc c'est un
petit peu
alors par contre on a mieux mesurer en
tout cas l'effet l'effet cocktail avec
tous les pesticides mais je rappelle
aussi que aux entiers comme dans tous
les pays tropicaux on peut pas la nature
elle se repose pas et qu'on peut pas
produire que ce soit les bananes ou
autres on peut pas
on peut pas le faire d'une façon
naturelle puisque les tous les insectes
les champignons
réapparaissent mais
par exemple l'origine de cancer il
n'existait pas quand on a commencé à
travailler donc on a eu des progrès mais
je trouve que on a quand même pas été
je dis en collectif je mets
en cause de personnes mais on aurait pu
espérer qu'au bout de 13 ans et du côté
de la dépollution des sols et du côté
de l'acceptation des populations
à pouvoir s'alimenter différemment et
prendre en compte le risque on aurait pu
aller plus loin c'est je dis bien un
avis purement personnel et c'est pas la
ville d'OPEX puisque quand on
remettra les conclusions ce sera des
conclusions que l'on discutera en commun
à l'OPEX en tout cas merci à chacun
d'entre vous et c'est quand même même si
on peut considérer qu'on aurait pu aller
plus loin à un grand progrès par rapport
aux maladies aux maladies
professionnelles
merci je vous laisse vous pouvez
assister si vous voulez la deuxième
partie ou sinon donc pour les
interlocuteurs de la deuxième partie on
reprend dans 3 minutes et vous voulez
bien le temps que on se salue les uns
les autres
je te laisse
la deuxième la deuxième table ronde
donc après avoir vu les répercussions
sur la les analyses sur la santé nous
allons revenir sur nous allons porter
parler des répercussions sociales que
cette pollution massive a eu sur les
Antilles alors nous allons accueillir
monsieur Justin Daniel qui est
professeur de sciences politiques à
l'université des Antilles madame Justine
Benin qui était le rapporteur de la
commission d'enquête à l'Assemblée
nationale sur l'utilisation de la
chlordécone et du paraguat Madame
Victoire jasmin qui est sénatrice de la
Guadeloupe madame Patricia Chatenet
rivaudeck et présidente de l'association
guadeloupéenne vivre et Monsieur André
Edouard pour le collectif martiniquais
alors excusez-moi je ne parle pas le
créole donc Liana pour déployer ma
clinique
je demanderai à chacun d'avoir une
intervention puisque vous êtes 1 2 3 3
et de 5 de d'environ 8 minutes maximum
chacun pour qu'après on puisse avoir le
débat comme vous avez vu le débat n'est
pas toujours forcément et les questions
un petit peu plus le temps alors
Monsieur
Monsieur Daniel monsieur Justin Daniel
je vous laisse nous présenter votre
point de vue
sur ce sujet en tant que professeur de
la science politique je sais que vous
nous avez écrit et déclaré que l'affaire
de la chlordécone a en partie contribué
à la défiance vis-à-vis de l'État et de
l'État en général je vous laisse la
parole
vous entend pas il faut peut-être ouvrir
le micro
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs mesdames et messieurs les
députés
je voudrais ajouter à la présentation
que je suis par ailleurs vice-président
du comité de pilotation scientifique
nationale dans le cadre du Plan Claude
et conquêtes
alors en introduction à nos échanges je
vais organiser mes propos autour de
trois séries de considération vous
prions de m'excuser pour le caractère
parfois depuis aussi de
métropole et on aura probablement
l'occasion dans discuter plus amplement
lors de la discussion qui va première
série de considération qui tourne autour
de la question qui vient d'être évoquée
de la défiance généralisée à l'égard des
autorités
on va le voir
ce qui peut constituer effectivement une
entrave la mise en oeuvre dispositifs
d'actions publics y compris le plan des
cône 4 ensuite je vous gagne deux mots
de l'enjeu qui me semble crucial de
l'information des populations
terminé par
ce que pouvait jouer l'activation dans
le levier dont nous parle beaucoup celui
de la démocratie participative
alors tout d'abord sur le premier point
la défiance à l'égard des autorités je
crois que dans notre territoire ce qui a
fondamentalement changé c'est la
perception que l'on peut avoir de l'État
dans un contexte de crise qui
s'apparente à un véritable scandale qui
débouche sur une écho anxiété nous
sommes là en présence d'un terrain qui
est favorable à la réactivation de
représentation qui sont associées à des
hiérarchies socioratiales
hérité de l'histoire éviter de
l'esclavage et également à des
revendications
identitaires qui peuvent être couplées à
un activisme politique qui déborde
les canaux habituels de l'expression
politique on a plus d'ailleurs mesuré
les effets à la Martinique par exemple
en 2020 à la veille du premier
confinement où il y avait des
mobilisations parfois un peu violentes
chaque samedi
s'agissant de l'évolution de la
perception et du rapport à ce dernier et
par de là vous voulez le rapport aux
institutions on est passé de l'idée d'un
État qui était perçu comme une sorte de
tomates
générateur de
d'égalité de liberté dans le
prolongement de l'abolition de
l'esclavage en un état qui est perçu
aujourd'hui
presque comme un organe étranger qui en
tout cas est frappé par une sorte
d'altérité et avec lequel les
populations antillaises entretiennent un
rapport plus que jamais ambival l'État
est à la fois le réceptacle de tous les
reproches notamment et sans doute des
groupes s'agissant du dossier qui nous
préoccupe ce matin vers la gestion des
crises et on a tendance
en même temps à le considérer comme le
premier et le dernier recours
y compris de la part des acteurs locaux
qui exerce des
responsabilité
s parallèlement cela on voit émerger au
sein de l'espace public des associations
certaines vous exprimés tout à l'heure
les clients développés une
ex et des savoirs concurrents qui leur
permettent de contester le monopole
entre guillemets de la parole officielle
il en résulte une perte de confiance
c'est un rapport de défiance à l'égard
de toutes les institutions et même du
personnel politique qu'il soit central
pour local
conséquence on assiste aux Antilles à
une politisation de l'enjeu sanitaire
lié à la question de la cour d'école à
travers l'ExAC
erbase d'accination
identitaire mais quelles affirmations
identitaires tendent à devenir l'une des
formes privilégiées d'expressions
politiques aux Antilles et on a bien vu
que lors des élections récentes
l'abstention avait battu tous les
renforts
va se traduit également par la prise en
charge de l'enjeu de la fleur du cône
par des coalitions qui sont de plus en
plus hétéroclite qui fonctionne parfois
sur le mode de l'horizontalité
au risque de s'enfermer pour certaines
d'entre elles dans une
rhétorique dénonciatrice qui n'est pas
nécessairement
positif pour serrer parfois difficile à
dépasser donc on a un contexte là qui
est extrêmement difficile et puis en
certaines circonstances peut se révéler
inflammable lorsque en particulier
plusieurs crises se télescope comme ça a
été le cas à la fin de l'année dernière
s'agissant de l'information des
populations
anti d'abord je voudrais dire que je
fais une distinction entre informations
et communications et la communication
reconnaissons l'un a été mauvaise
s'agissant de la gestion des dossiers de
l'accordéon notamment lorsqu'il est
assuré par l'État et on peut le
comprendre puisque l'État assez est
placé dans une situation pour le moins
inconfortable pour les raisons évidents
certes des progrès ont été réalisés et
je crois qu'il faut absolument
poursuivre dans la voie de la
transparence c'est l'une des conditions
pour rétablir cette confiance
c'est la difficulté que nous éprouvons
sur le terrain
création des informations les
informations circulent mais elle
n'atteigne pas nécessairement leur cible
d'autant plus que souvent elle mélange
dans un contexte
d'incertitudes et d'inquiétudes
exacerbées donc un mélange des données
dont le scientifique et de
considérations relatives aux attentes
immédiates des populations je voudrais
prendre deux exemples
pour le montrer combien de personnes au
sein des populations antillaise maîtrise
le débat le plus technique autour des
limites maximales de résidus qui
conditionne les choix que ces personnes
doivent faire en matière de consommation
autre débat
S
les informations établies fiables
vérifier et qui sont parfois concurrence
avec les
inepties entre guillemets qui circulent
sur les réseaux sociaux avec comment
conseiller d'autres informations avec
des pratiques qui sont culturellement
ancrées et qui sont présentés comme
constitutive d'une
identité que l'on considère par rapport
par ailleurs comme étant menacé ce sont
l'exemple ici de la pêche de crevettes
en eau douce et on dit ça a été confirmé
tout à l'heure que les eaux douces
durant la période parce qu'elle a la
Martinique les hommes qui considèrent
cela comme faisant partie de notre
identité donc il y a une
difficulté
[Musique]
toujours à propos de l'information je
voudrais souligner ici le paradoxe que
j'ai pu observer lors de l'élaboration
du Plan coordonnées je me suis rendu
compte que finalement tous les plans qui
ont été précédé le quatrième du même nom
était parfois par ces inaperçus en
dehors bien évidemment des acteurs qui
étaient directement concernés et pour la
population c'était pas du tout
le cas donc souvent nous avons tendance
à ramener ces problèmes à des
considérations relatives au moyen sans
doute
pour le niveau des moyens mieux on
luttera contre cette contamination et
cette pollution généralisée
le corps mais dans la balance des moyens
autrement plus important que ceux qui
ont poussé devant mais il s'agit
également et surtout
j'y reviens d'une difficulté
d'appropriation des dispositifs par les
acteurs et par les ressentis
c'est-à-dire les politiques les publics
cibles les populations cibles de
l'action
je veux dire que dans le territoire
comme la Guadeloupe et la Martinique la
simple édiction d'une norme censée être
connu en vertu du précepte nul n'est
censé ignorer la loi la simple
prédiction de cette norme ne signifie
pas son effectivité les réticences voire
les résistances dans le contexte local
peuvent être extrêmement fortes et il
faut il faut les les combattants comment
améliorer les choses puisque on pense
nous préoccupe je crois que
pour
une information appropriée et il faut il
faut pas avancer d'organiser des forums
ou les points de vue sont échangés de
façon à se mettre d'accord sur un simple
minimum de connaissance et de savoir
partager il faut veiller à rendre
accessible les informations au plus
grand nombre en mobilisant tous les
vecteurs possibles s'agit pas de
concurrencer les réseaux sociaux les
réseaux sociaux peuvent avoir un côté
positif pour que les investir pour faire
passer certaines informations pour
toucher c'était une catégorie de la
circulation à faire un gros travail de
traduction des informations disponibles
y compris des informations sur le plan
scientifique c'est une grosse
ville nous autres scientifiques nous ne
sommes pas armés pour faire de la
médiation
le cas nous exprimons dans des colloques
et bien notre langage n'est pas
nécessairement accessible donc il y a ce
gros travail de médiation scientifique
qui est préconisé d'ailleurs par le CPSM
et donc j'ai parlé tout à l'heure et
c'est un véritable métier qui d'ailleurs
étant en émergent
je voudrais terminer par quelques
considérations sur la démocratie
participative en tant qu'elle peut être
les deux
le réponse un élément pas la réponse
bien évidemment
à condition de lui donner un contenu et
un sens tout en étant cons
cient les limites sont connues je ne
monte rien je veux pas inventer de vous
l'eau chaude je pense que les
parlementaires qui nous écoutent ce
matin connaissent bien la difficulté on
sait que quand on met en place des
dispositifs de participation citoyenne
et bien préc
isément d'une faible
implique des citoyens
qui est doublé de retraite généralement
des populations précaires et là il faut
que ça a des populations crucléaires
ou encore au profit des détenteurs de la
parole ne s'exprime à travers ces
dispositifs mais est-ce que ce que
l'habitude déjà de s'exprimer donc c'est
un combat qu'il faut mener sur ce
terrain là néanmoins s'agissant de la
chloriculton de la crise du scandale ça
te faiblesse que je signale à l'instant
peut me semble-t-il être
commencez par la nature des enjeux parce
que tout le monde se sent concerné aux
Antibes et par sa dimension
conflictuelle faisant
quelque chose qui peut paraître négatif
parce que
quelque chose de positif cela peut
devenir mobilisation partant de là je
pense
qu'il faut apprendre
à se défaire de toute posture sur le
monde et de toute démarche en forme de
validation et c'est vrai en particulier
pour l'État en forme de validation de
décision que déjà été
la leçon a été tirée puisque moi j'ai eu
principal élaboration du plan
coordonnées 4 on n'est pas allé jusqu'au
bout pour des concrétiser à la crise de
sanitaire mais effectivement on était
conscient de cet enjeu là deuxième
élément il faut réhabiliter l'espace
public en libérant la parole il faut la
donner à tout le monde aux experts aux
associations aux scientifiques ont
décidés
pas les controverses sociotechnique et
pour se faire il faut mobiliser les
outils comme les forums hybrides qui
permettent de croiser les différents
types de savoir et et de connaissance
c'est un exercice difficile j'en suis
conscient qui nécessite là aussi de
jouer la transparence afin d'approprier
cette faciliter pardon c'est
d'appropriation des
travaux d'accès c'est très inégalement
réparti au sein des sociétés
donc il nous faut travailler à
produit sa voix
de la seule condition
pour s'inscrire dans une démarche de
co-construction avec la difficulté qu'il
ne faut pas négliger
il faut éviter en même temps
dans un contexte de décrédibilisation de
la parole scientifique et plus largement
de la parole publique de tomber dans une
relativisme absolu en disant que toutes
les connaissances de toutes les femmes
de savoir se valent
on mesure ici l'intérêt de mobiliser les
ressources de sciences humaines et
ales qui ont été des ateliers maintenus
à l'écart du plan des comptes 3 j'ai eu
l'occasion de rappeler de l'évaluation
de ce plan des congrès son temps
et je me félicite aujourd'hui du fait
que l'appel à projet spécifique 2022 de
la NR de la gestion nationale
de la recherche dont on connaîtra les
résultats d'ici quelques semaines et
bien
cet appel à projet a le mérite de placer
les sciences humaines de social au
centre-ville
et en les faisant fonctionner en étoile
articulation avec les casques dite dur
voilà les quelques propos que je voulais
mais merci merci professeur merci pour
cette éclairage
et j'espère que
nous répondons avec cette table ronde de
l'OPEX aujourd'hui à vous
recommandations de réhabilitation
puisqu'on donne la parole à des
scientifiques à des chercheurs à des
politiques
mais aussi à des associations donc
j'espère que on répondra non pas à toute
la problématique de accordéon mais que
l'on arrive que l'on arrive
effectivement à étendre cette parole
alors je passe maintenant
le micro et l'image à Madame Justine
Benin
qui a été rapporté
porteurs de la mission sur la pollution
à la chlore des cônes à l'Assemblée
nationale vous avez la parole madame
Bénin
merci madame la Présidente tout d'abord
je souhaite vous remercier de m'avoir
invité madame la sénatrice vocale vous
dire MERCI pour parler de ce sujet au
combien importantes et douloureux pour
les territoires de Guadeloupe et
Martinique mais aussi et surtout pour
l'ensemble de ces populations là en fait
durant 6 mois nous avons entendu avec
dans le cadre de la commission d'enquête
sous la pollution sur des cônes avec le
président de cette commission d'enquête
et moi même rapporteur Serge latini nous
avons durant six mois entendu tous les
acteurs concernés par cette pollution
nous avons rencontré aussi bien les
agences sanitaires les administrations
centrales les experts les scientifiques
mais nous avons été aussi au contact des
populations Guadeloupe et Martinique et
rencontrer l'ensemble des instances
locales l'ensemble des associations des
associations qui sont aussi sous cette
table ronde mais aussi les agriculteurs
les marins-pêcheurs et différentes
populations et vous dire en tout cas
près de 150 personnalités que nous avons
additionné un travail de longue haleine
de précision un travail très important
aussi qui a été réalisé sur les archives
que nous ont transmis le ministère de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation parce
que ces archives ont été extrêmement
précieux pour nous puisqu'elles nous ont
permis de retracer mais vraiment de
retracer très clairement et très
précisément l'histoire même de cette
pollution et d'apporter des réponses
quant aux responsabilités vous savez
parce que l'objectif de cette commission
d'enquête c'était déjà et bien apporter
des réponses sur la responsabilité
publique et au privée et vous l'avez vu
nous avons fait ce travail de minutie ou
nous tombons effectivement par rapport à
ces archives ou la responsabilité de
l'État est engagé et vous avez vu lors
de ces auditions nous avons différents
ministres qui sont venus successivement
aussi bien la ministre de la santé des
outre-mer ou de l'agriculture qui ont
affirmé la responsabilité de l'État dans
cette pollution et cet empoisonnement
des terres de Guadeloupe et de
Martinique
on le sait c'est vrai que la Guadeloupe
et la Martinique font face à une
contamination durable et généralisée du
plan d'école c'était avant moi l'on dit
dans les sols dans les eaux et parfois
même dans l'alimentation en matière de
santé d'abord je ne vais pas épiloguer
mais c'est très important de le dire des
risques sanitaires qui sont aujourd'hui
mal quantifiés lorsqu'on sait que 90%
des populations du clan des cônes dans
le sang or il est établi que le chlore
des cônes possède des effets
cancérigènes ainsi que des étapes des
impacts pardon possible sur la
prématurité des naissances et le
développement cognitif de nouveau-né
ensuite nous avons abordé la question
des risques sanitaires durant nos
travaux tous les experts scientifiques
auditionnelles le professeur mutinier
qui était sur l'autre table ronde ainsi
que l'ensemble de ceux qui ont participé
ont reconnu le caractère cancérogène du
chlorecome et le risque lié au cancer de
la prostate
pas qu'il faut dire dans cette table
ronde c'est que les populations vivent
dans un climat assez anxiogène car tous
les effets du clanécone ne sont pas
encore appréhendés et les citoyens sont
souvent peu informés je vous rejoins
monsieur le professeur quand vous dites
vous faites la différence entre
information et communication sachant que
90% de la population est contaminée
nombreux sont ceux qui ont recours à des
analyses de sang pour se faire tester
leur chlordécone or ces personnes ne
font l'objet d'aucun suivi et ne
bénéficient d'aucune explication
d'aucune prise en charge d'aucune
information pour les aider à interpréter
leur analyse les accompagner et les
conseillers à ces difficultés là
s'ajoutent ou la Guadeloupe et la
Martinique aussi la pollution qui
impacte fortement les maraîchers les
producteurs de fruits les éleveurs ainsi
que les marré pêcheurs ces difficultés
là sont de plusieurs ordres
avec des parcelles contaminées sur
lequel il n'est plus possible de
cultiver des produits dit sensibles des
légumes racines et qui habitent assez
concombre pastèque et lors de nos
travaux sur le terrain nous n'avons plus
que constater les défaillances dans
l'accompagnement des agriculteurs mais
aussi des marins pêcheurs qui souffrent
également de profondes difficultés suite
aux différents arrêtés d'interdiction de
pêche prise sur les zones côtières
contaminées le nombre de marins pêcheurs
à diminué de près de 50% 10 ans et
environ 75% des produits de la mer qui
sont consommés aujourd'hui dans les
territoires d'un Guadeloupe et de
Martinique sont importés alors que la
Guadeloupe et la Martinique sont les
plus gros sont parmi les plus gros
consommateurs de poissons au monde je le
dis il s'agit il s'agissait pour nous à
l'époque dans le cadre de cette
commission d'enquête mais aujourd'hui
cela court toujours de restaurer la
confiance des consommateurs envers nos
produits locaux mais aussi dans
restaurer la confiance vis-à-vis de nos
agriculteurs des marins-pêcheurs et tout
simplement de la population en matière
de pêche aussi il faut amplifier nous
l'avons vu il fallait amplifier les
efforts parce que les marins-pêcheurs se
sont faits abandonnés face aux
difficultés qu'il supportait alors que
leur secteur d'activité devait être
valorisé surtout en Guadeloupe tout
comme en Martinique nous vous avons plus
de mer que de terre c'est vous dire au
combien la question sociale est
importante je vous parle de difficultés
des agriculteurs démarrer un pêcheurs
des populations pour vous montrer et
bien que cette défiance cette défiance
vis-à-vis des politiques publiques cette
défiance vis-à-vis de l'État et
vécu et se vit naturellement dans ce
territoire après cet empoisonnement et
cette pollution encore d'école nos
travaux ont aussi cette époque mise en
lumière les défaillances profondes en
matière de recherche scientifique sur le
plan d'école oui d'une part concernant
la recherche médicale sur les impacts du
plan des cônes dans la santé et ça part
attribuable dans les pathologies qu'il
peut occasionner comme le cancer de la
prostate mais nous l'avons vu maladie
professionnelle mais également dans la
recherche ou les techniques de
dépollution je tiens à souligner que des
chercheurs de haut niveau sont
intéressés par la problématique du plan
d'école je vous ai entendu parler de
l'appel à projetain que je suis
effectivement aussi les ressources
humaines existent elles sont bien là que
ce soit région parisienne et notamment
dans les grands instituts mais aussi aux
Antilles mais pour autant à l'époque où
nous avions mené la Commission et bien
il y avait des difficultés qui
perdureraient d'abord il y avait un
manque de coordination entre tous les
acteurs de la recherche et aussi entre
la recherche fondamentale et la
recherche expérimentale
quand les populations voyaient toutes
ces difficultés ici et là au niveau des
filières au niveau de la recherche et
bien c'est vous dire au combien cette
société et bien s'interroger et prenait
cette commission d'enquête pour une
première réponse à différentes
interrogations par rapport à leur vécu
et à voir que leur terre et bien été
empoisonné pour des siècles et des
siècles vous dire que
nous avons effectué des propositions au
nombre de 59
dans le cadre du rapport de la
commission d'enquête sur le clan des
cônes avec le Président Monsieur si
adjectif d'ailleurs pour nous présentez
pas toutes les recommandations
je voulais vous dire que
dans le cadre de cette de cette
commission d'enquête nous avions fait le
constat de loup de défaillance en
matière de communication d'informatique
nous avions fait le constat de Lourdes
défaillance en matière des différents
planteurs des cônes 1 2 3 nous avions
fait le constat des défaillances par
rapport aux archives et bien de l'État
ce qui trouve clairement la
responsabilité de l'État dans cette
pollution au chlore des codes c'est vous
dire que sur l'ensemble de ces aspects
que je viens d'énumérer c'est normal
qu'il y ait autant de défiance défiance
vis-à-vis de l'État vis-à-vis de des
politiques publiques de l'État mis en
place sur nos territoires de Guadeloupe
et de Martinique vous l'avez vu par
rapport à la crise sociale vous avez vu
par rapport à la crise sanitaire mais
vous l'avez vu aussi dans le cadre et
bien des
des résultats des différentes élections
que nous avons eu voilà ce que je tenais
à dire en me basant spécifiquement sur
le rapport travailler et bien avec à
l'époque mon collègue Sergio merci
beaucoup madame Bénin et on sent que
vous vivez encore complètement votre
votre rapport et que vous le connaissez
parfaitement maintenant j'ai passé la
parole à une autre collègue cette fois
c'est natrice qui est victoire au jasmin
qui en 2009 en 2019 a réussi à faire
voter un amendement qui a permis le
remboursement des tests sanguins pour
déterminer le taux de chlore d'école
vous en avez parlé madame Bénin en
disant que il y a les tests mais il y a
pas de de suivi sanitaire moi je vois
qu'il y a des tests alors que 10 ans
auparavant il y avait même pas la
possibilité de
de test il fallait les envoyer en
Belgique au Canada ou je ne sais pas où
et vous avez même fait voter la
majoration de 2 millions d'euros de
crédit en 2020 pour lutter contre
l'exposition
de la population de la Martinique et de
la Guadeloupe en tout cas nous avons la
deux
parlementaires très engagés sur le plan
de la cornécone alors cher victoire
quelle est ta vision sur la situation
sociale de la chlordécone
en Guadeloupe merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente je remercie je félicite
Justine pour son exposé et dans le loyer
de tout ce qui a été dit je poursuivre
d'une part pour dire que au début
évidemment il y a eu des tests je vais
commencer par cette partie là il y a eu
des tests dont il y a pas de suivi mais
qui était réalisable ailleurs que sur
notre territoire et en plus il des
premiers qui étaient disponibles à la
Martinique mais il fallait que les
personnes prennent en charge eux-mêmes
l'intégralité des frais et là ça crée
quand même des grandes disparités ça
c'est un premier sujet donc c'est ce qui
a motivé également le fait que j'ai eu
envie de proposer cette
fléchir un budget pour permettre
évidemment la prise en charge mais au
niveau sanitaire il y a eu beaucoup de
conséquences au niveau de la santé ça a
été dit à la fois par le professeur
mystifier certains autres intervenants
de la première table ronde y compris par
Justine en tant que juste madame
Justinien en tant que rapporteur mais il
y a eu beaucoup de conséquences
et encore aujourd'hui elles sont perçus
vécus difficilement par les familles
pourquoi parce qu'au niveau de
l'agriculture nous sommes quand même des
territoires à vocation agricoles en
premier lieu et au niveau de
l'agriculture il y a une perte de
fonciers agricole dans un premier temps
une perte de valeur du foncier
disponible pour certaines familles qui
jusque là pouvait à la fois la plupart
du temps les hommes les perds eux ils
travaillaient dans les bananes c'est
vrai mais les maires faisaient le jardin
créole à proximité de la maison et là on
a parlé récemment du pouvoir d'achat il
est aussi conséquences et bien là ça
contribué le fait de pouvoir de ne plus
pouvoir faire la culture de proximité
dans les jardins familiaux et bien ça a
posé un certain nombre de problèmes même
si aujourd'hui lire la RS c'est un
nombre de partenaires ont mis en place
les jardins avec Jafar pour le choix des
produits on voit bien qu'il y a quand
même difficile au niveau des capacité
des familles à pouvoir se nourrir
correctement alors que les produits qui
étaient identifiés comme étant ceux
qu'on pouvait utiliser et s'il y en a
cité quelques-uns ce sont des produits
indus glycémique bas donc ce qui fait
que aujourd'hui les gens ont changé les
habitudes alimentaires il y a beaucoup
de centenaires chez nous beaucoup de
centenaires encore aujourd'hui j'ai vu
qu'on fait un centenaire dans la Master
à donc il y a des personnes qui ont
mangé un certain moment un certain
produit qui ont permis qu'il soit
instantanés et qui vont jusqu'à 106 ans
aujourd'hui maintenant il y a des
conséquences qui sont graves mais je
crois que la situation c'était le
dernier au début et c'est ça déni là qui
a été mal vécu parce que quand les
premières personnes qui ont eu des
conséquences sur leur santé ont commencé
à être malade donc les aidants
aujourd'hui on parle des dents mais tous
les proches de la famille étaient
impactés une fois par la maladie de
celui qui était porteur de revenus de
reminage mais aussi par rapport aux
enfants et à tous ceux qui étaient là et
qui continuaient à consommer les
produits de la terre parce que par mes
connaissances peut-être d'autre part
tous les équipements aujourd'hui on
parle beaucoup d'équipements de
protection dans divers domaines de prise
en charge des salariés il y avait pas
encore tout cela donc il y a eu des
conséquences humaines et il y a pas eu
des couples à ce moment-là donc
aujourd'hui on a les enfants de ces
personnes là sont devenues des adultes
ils ont probablement ça pour certains
les petits enfants et on sait très bien
que c'est très douloureux dans les
familles quand il y a des personnes qui
successivement ont eu des maladies et
qui n'avaient pas forcément de réponse
pour ce qui concerne l'élevage c'est
aussi un sujet sur ces territoires parce
qu'il y a eu évidemment ce n'est pas
fait de façon exhaustive mais il y a eu
des analyses des sols une cartographie
qui emplacement n'est pas faite sur
l'ensemble du territoire et pour le
moment et là le madame la Présidente on
le disiez évidemment
ça c'est aussi un problème parce que il
y a peut-être encore les lieux où il y
aurait certains il a monsieur qui me
disait qu'il y avait pas que les
problèmes de chloriculteurs d'autres
molécules mais ce sont aussi des sujets
à la fois pour l'élevage pour les
pêcheurs alors c'est dramatique ça a été
dit mais c'est dramatique parce qu'en
fait les pêcheurs qui payent des rôles
qui ont des bateaux qui payent beaucoup
de choses en fait et en même temps ils
doivent aussi payer le gasoil par
exemple pour leur bateau ils doivent
aller de plus en plus loin nous avons
parlé récemment dit pouvoir d'achat
geler évoqué parce que pour pêcher sur
nos côtes étant il y a des zones de
toute façon qui pour sur lesquelles ils
ne peuvent plus pêcher ils seraient en
infraction donc ils sont obligés d'aller
de plus en plus loin donc ils ont des
choix qui sont quelquefois douloureux
parce que on retrouve quelques fois dans
des hommes territoriales qui ne sont pas
les nôtres donc ils peuvent se faire
confisquer leur matériel donc là c'est
un vrai sujet en plus alors des surcos
parce que là on a de l'énergie on a tous
les secours qui sont liés à cette assez
pratique là donc il y a beaucoup de
jeunes pêcheurs mais on voit qu'ils sont
de plus en plus
contraire de laisser tomber parce qu'ils
sont en souffrance et ils se sont
manifestés à mon corps parce qu'il y
avait des secours considérables et il
n'avait pas une écoute particulière de
la part de ceux qui pourraient les aider
il y a le côté de la de la déjà plus ou
moins dit de la santé mais la qualité de
l'eau alors c'est vrai que chez nous sur
notre territoire en particulier en
Guadeloupe il y a des problèmes de qui
sont liés à d'autres problématiques
concernant l'usure et la non prise en
compte en tout cas de certaines parties
de nos réseaux mais il y a la qualité de
l'eau et là ceux qui regrettable c'est
aussi les normes parce qu'on devrait
avoir des normes nuls pas d'un homme
avec un tour et visuel et aujourd'hui
quand on voit la qualité de l'eau on
voit il y a qu'il y a un taux résiduel
qui est toléré donc ça ne devrait pas
parce que ça a un impact aussi sur la
sur la santé des gens il y a un taux
résiduel quelquefois et là on devrait
pas avoir le chloricon dans l'eau qui
est utilisée et consommer pour la
boisson alors de plus en plus surtout un
suite au passage de la tempête qui est
récemment on voit que ici et là il y a
beaucoup de communiquer qui interdisent
l'utilisation de l'eau potable pour le
brossage des dents pour
l'alimentation donc en fait pour les
ménages au niveau social ça cause aussi
un budget parce qu'il faut acheter de
l'eau pour se laver quelquefois pour se
brosser les dents pour boire et là c'est
quand même compliqué
des territoires où il y a un taux de
chômage très important où il y a un taux
de chômage des femmes très important et
les familles monoparentales sont aussi
très important de chez nous donc même si
il y a une volonté de prendre en compte
ces situations là par les collectivités
mais on voit qu'il y a aussi un impact
sur les collectivités que ce soit les
communes les conseils départementaux en
fait toutes les collectivités sont
confrontées parce que les personnes ont
recours de plus en plus au CCAS au
conseil départemental à tous tout ce
qu'il y a comme solidarité et à cela
s'ajoutent évidemment tout ce que les
différentes associations caritatives
reconnues ça peut être bon je n'ai pas
cité pour en oublier mais on est déjà
une mobilisation également par la
solidarité à la fois nationale mais
aussi au niveau local avec les
associations avec certains nombres
d'associations et de personnes qui
prennent aussi des initiatives
individuelles donc il y a vraiment
prendre en compte cette situation et il
y a des alertes des alertes et ce qu'il
y a c'est que avec le plan des conquête
moi je crois qu'il y a peut-être des
bonnes initiatives mais il faut
davantage et là ça a été dit par le
professeur d'université il faut
davantage impliquer à la fois les
associations mais apporter les
informations à proximité parce qu'en
fait il y a des informations qui sont
peut-être juste qui sont validés qui
sont pertinentes mais qui sont méconnues
par les personnes qui sont à proximité
et les moyens limités de certaines
personnes les contraignent à faire du
MES usages je dirais de certains de
certains produits il y a aussi l'absence
de contrôle il faudrait qu'il y ait plus
de contrôle parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
ventes informelles parce qu'il y a pas
il y a peut-être une volonté de la part
de la Chambre d'agriculture et de toute
ceux qui contribuent à améliorer la
qualité de l'alimentation et de la prise
en compte de ces problématiques là mais
il y a des ventes informelles qui se
font un peu sur le bord du chemin il
faudrait qu'il y ait des moyens de
contrôle dans la traçabilité et des
produits qui arrivent chez nous parce
qu'il y a une question de non les
européenne il est énorme française
nous contraignent contraignent les
agriculteurs de plus en plus à utiliser
un certain
je dirais à ne pas utiliser certains
produits ou en tout cas ils indiquent
lesquels utiliser pour justement ne pas
mettre en danger la santé humaine et là
ce qui se passe c'est que beaucoup de
produits qui viennent d'autres pays je
me suis que le Brésil par exemple et
certaines îles de la Caraïbes qui
continuent à ne pas rester dans les
normes qui ne sont pas contraintes par
les mêmes normes et bien il y a une
concurrence il y a un véritable une
concurrence entre certains produits qui
arrivent ce territoire national qui ne
répondent pas aux normes européennes et
on a française et en même temps qu'il
faut concurrence à au produit de nos
agriculteurs et et de nos pécheurs ainsi
que de nos éleveurs alors résultat ces
produits quelquefois dit de dégagement
parce qu'ils sont à bas coût et bien
pour les ménages qui sont en des gens
difficultés qui n'ont pas beaucoup de
moyens et bien c'est un moyen de recours
et là on est en train de créer d'autres
difficultés sur les moyens le long terme
donc je crois qu'il faudrait que nous
puissions tous et toutes travailler pour
que maintenant et de plus en plus parce
que il y a vraiment une motivation pour
que les agriculteurs et toute leur place
même si il y a des difficultés pour la
foncier là ça fait l'association la SPA
par exemple c'est pas la situation c'est
la société d'aménagement foncier pour ce
cru d'alarme justement parce qu'il y a
aussi des disparités qui sont liées au
fait que les dotations qui sont données
aux affaires pour permettre de mieux
accompagner les collectivités et pour
identifier vraiment les foncier agricole
ça pose problème donc aujourd'hui on
parle de souveraineté alimentaire je
crois qu'il faudrait vraiment prendre à
bras le col l'ensemble de ces
problématiques concernant la méfiance
rapidement il y a une méfiance il y a
une suspicion il y a une différence même
de tous les élus quel que soit leur
strates c'est à dire que c'est aussi
l'état ça a été dit mais ce sont les
élus de proximité qu'on accuse qu'il
soit à toi à raison qu'on accuse d'avoir
cautionné un certain nombre votre
disposition qui n'auraient pas été prise
donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui nous devons
humaniser davantage les dispositions que
nous prenons prenons contre les choses
mais les prendre en charge de façon très
sérieux c'est déjà ça s'améliore on peut
pas dire que les choses ne s'améliorent
pas avec également le plan 4 avec
l'implication de plus en plus des
associations qui ont supporté plein à un
moment donné pour qu'elle soit entendu
il faut le dire mais aujourd'hui je
crois que il est temps que nous
puissions à la fois prendre en compte la
souffrance des familles parce que il y a
quand même une souffrance quand on voit
qu'il y a des enfants et les adultes en
fait bon je vais pas revenir sur la
santé mais il faut vraiment que nous
puissions collectivement et grâce à vous
également prendre en compte les
problématiques pour mieux les régler
merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup victoire
je me permets simplement tu as parlé des
produits agricoles de citer un travail
auquel j'avais participé dans le cadre
de la délégation d'outre-mer je suis
plus en 2016 ou 2017 justement sur
l'agriculture de l'outre-mer et sur les
normes qu'on imposait dans nos
outre-merdes alors parfois on leur
impose des normes qui sont les normes
qu'on impose en Pologne et ou dans le
Berry alors que le climat est pas le
même et l'importation des produits qui
qui font concurrence et qui ne sont pas
soumis au même nom mais ça c'est le
problème enfin c'est un problème général
mais je trouve encore plus aiguë lorsque
l'on est sur un territoire aussi étroit
que les Antilles alors vous avez vu que
on donne la parole à la fois aux élus de
Guadeloupe Martinique et pour les
associations nous avons fait donc la
même chose alors
je vais donner la parole à Madame
Patricia Châtenay rivaudet on a eu votre
nom avant c'est pas que je fasse une
association
avant l'autre mais on a eu connaissance
auparavant de
votre de votre nom donc vous représentez
l'association en guadeloupéenne vivre
je vais nous allons vous entendre
compléter sans doute ce que viennent de
dire tous nos précédents interlocuteurs
et intervenants sur le ressenti et le
ressenti sur le plan social de la
pollution à l'atlanticone
il faut que vous ouvriez votre micro
en fait tous pareil on le ferme avant de
parler et après on oublie de l'ouvrir
bonjour madame la madame la signatrice
madame
au président de toutes les personnes qui
sont ici présentes en vous rase et
qualité l'association Vivre ces
adhérents ses partenaires et moi-même
mon humble position de Présidente nous
vous remercions de nous donner le temps
d'échange et ce temps de partage sur
notre vision
de la situation actuelle en Guadeloupe
comme en Martinique
je viens ici dans cet instant parler
humblement
à travers la voix de nos adhérents à
travers la voix de nos partenaires dont
il y en a je voulais problématiques pour
présenter par Monsieur Édouard
à travers nos familles à travers nos
parents et amis et particulièrement à
travers nos
proches qui sont soit actuellement en
soins par rapport à des maladies
métaboliques
en traitement et bien entendu nous
sommes aussi la voix de nos défunts de
toutes les victimes et n'oubliables que
nous avons vu souffrir à travers toutes
ces maladies métaboliques nous avons un
regard spécifique pour les femmes
ouvrières agricoles qui ont été oubliés
par l'État qui ont été oubliés dans le
cadre de la des fonds d'indemnisation et
qui dans leur chair et dans leurs
pensées vivent une forme de
discrimination
nous venons ici vous dire que
l'OMS dit que la santé environnementale
comprend les aspects de la santé humaine
y compris la qualité de la vie ils sont
déterminés par des facteurs physiques
chimiques biologique sociaux
psychosociaux et esthétique de notre
environnement
la santé veulentale concerne également
la politique et les pratiques de gestion
de réception de contrôle et de
prévention des facteurs environnementaux
susceptibles
d'affecter la santé des générations
actuelles et futures
se précisément ce que nous vivons en
Guadeloupe et en Martinique depuis plus
de 40 ans avec ce que ce scandale de
contamination et de pollution sur les
territoires de Guadeloupe et de Martine
nous venons vous dire aussi que en
Guadeloupe comme en Martinique des
familles entières des personnes qui
n'ont jamais de leur vie ni toucher ni
emprunter ni utilisé que l'on
et toute ce type de pesticides
ont perdu des parents
souffrent avec donc les parents qui sont
en traitement
et vont probablement encore avoir à
subir des impacts psychosociaux et des
impacts économiques qui sont de vrais
scandales
nous venons vous dire aussi en
Guadeloupe comme en Martinique
les peuples meurent en silence parce
qu'ils sont exposés depuis longtemps et
ainsi d'oieusement à un pesticide et à
des cocktails de pesticides qui sont
terriblesment dangereux et mortifères
nous venons aussi vous dire
et nous vous remercions de nouveaux pour
ce temps de parole que bien qu'il ait
des efforts qui a été fait ces dernières
années à travers les différents plans
d'économes à travers les mobilisations à
travers une forme de prise de conscience
qui est quand même un peu infantilisante
jusqu'à ce jour
que il est urgent d'entendre la
souffrance des peuples il est urgent de
parler à une explosion sociale qui sera
probablement terrible parce que la
conjonction
de l'ensemble de ses souffrances et de
l'ensemble des inégalités et de ses
justice feront que les personnes
touchées et leurs collatéraux
n'accepteront plus ces inégalités nous
venons aussi vous dire que le sentiment
de colère
d'injustice de défiance
de génocide latin dont certains parlent
envers les peuples de Guadeloupe et de
Martinique
constitue une forme de cocotte-minute
qu'il faut vite donc il faut vite
enlever la soupe
les accès et les manifestations
pacifiques que nous nous
accompagnons
peuvent à n'importe quel moment
laisser cours à des excès de violence
que nous ne pouvons pas soutenir
mais nous attirons l'attention de tous
sur la répression
sur les arrestations sur le manque de
dialogue avec certains qui souffrent et
qui ne trouve de solutions pour pouvoir
communiquer
qu'en étant dans des gestes qui ne sont
pas forcément égaux
nous disons aussi
que des personnes
âgées ou des personnes qui ont toujours
eu que leur jardin créole
et qui ne peuvent plus les exploiter
parce que
ces terrains sont chlore déconnés
et qui se retrouvent à devoir
dépasser leur budget à être dans des
situations de dépenses extrêmes parce
que ce qu'elles ont planté ou ce
qu'elles avaient pour participer à leur
à leurs besoins alimentaires ne sont
plus viables sont contaminés nous devons
aussi dire ces problèmes de
contamination de chlore des cônes dans
l'eau qui font que les familles entières
sont obligées de posséder à des dépenses
complémentaires d'achat de bouteilles
d'eau
constitue à dégrader
leur situation actuelle
il faut penser que les ouvriers
agricoles les ouvrières agricoles les
agriculteurs les maraîchers les éleveurs
les pêcheurs les aquacultures les
giteurs vivent depuis des années dans un
désastre économique ou faillite se
multiplient ou effondrement de famille
se constituent pour des divorces
multiplient pour des activités
professionnelles prennent fin pour des
endettements se multiplient des
difficultés familiales
se multiplient ou des familles entières
et des étudiants soutenus par des
parents
on dit abandonner leurs études
nous devons dire qu'il y a des efforts
qui sont faits par un plan déconne qui
est présenté qui nous a été prendre des
entité à 92 millions sur la période de
2021-2026 pour deux territoires qui
totalise en moyenne près de 790 000
âmes
nous faisons le rapport nous sommes sur
19,40 € par habitant et par an
est-ce que ce monde est sérieux
est-ce que
nous pouvons dire qu'avec 19,40
par an par habitant par martiniquais pas
guadeloupéen nous couvrons les besoins
qui doivent être prises en compte dans
le cadre de ce scandale et des préjudice
subi par chacune de ces personnes
nous disons aussi
si des solutions existent
la communication
les modes d'information les modalités
d'apprentissage sont actuellement
totalement insuffisants
il y a des personnes qui ont besoin
d'être accompagnés pour s'assurer que ce
qu'elles vont pouvoir planter chez elle
ou ce qu'elle pouvait acheter ou ce
qu'elles vont pouvoir consommer ou faire
consommer à leur famille
soit sain
il y a des personnes qui vivent des
peurs et il y a une approche qui doit
être véritablement vécue c'est
particulièrement cette approche de la
place de l'accompagnement psychologique
de toutes les personnes qui ont été
reconnu comme contaminé qui ont fait des
tests certains ont été accompagnés
certaines ne le sont pas il y a
véritablement
urgence à ce que les impacts
psychosociaux soient pris en compte et
qu'il y a une forme de communication et
d'accompagnement qui aille vers les
personnes à leur domicile
à leur domicile
parce que certaines personnes n'ont plus
la force de se rendre niala RS ni dans
des pharmacies nulle part parce qu'elles
ont accompagné les leurs propres
familles et que si elles se savent
toucher elles n'ont plus la force de
faire les démarches nous voulons dire
aussi qu'il est urgent de sacraliser les
terres qui n'ont pas été contaminés sur
les territoires de Guadeloupe de Martine
et qu'il faille faire très vite pour
éviter ces transbordements de terre
entre terre contaminée tiens qui ne le
sont pas
nous voudrions dire aussi
l'accompagnement des professionnels tous
les professionnels que nous avons fait
préalablement énumérées
il doit être aussi à base de données de
thérapie il doit pouvoir permettre à
cette personne de pouvoir librement
s'exprimer sans avoir honte de ce
qu'elle vivent parce que beaucoup de
personnes victimes
culpabilise de leur situation
culpabilise du fait que leurs parents
souffrent et que eux-mêmes étant malade
ils ne peuvent pas subvenir aux besoins
de leurs parents
donc il convient d'accompagner des
familles entières
et que c'est accompagnement soit
justement fait en fonction des besoins
individualisés
pour qu'on puisse donner la parole à
l'autre association avant la fin de de
la soirée
je voudrais juste te dire que vous savez
que nous nous avons fait des
propositions d'association vivre nous
avons fait des propositions pour qu'il y
ait une Commission Justice et vérité qui
soit mise en oeuvre pour que cette
Commission puisse pouvoir justement
amener le pédagogique et amener
l'accompagnement justement sur ce
scandale pour que en fait que ce sont
desdemnisations ne soient pas uniquement
consacré aux maladies professionnelles
et particulièrement la prostate mais à
toutes les maladies qui touchent aussi
bien les femmes parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup plus d'ouvrières agricoles nous
voulons ainsi dire que il faut élaborer
un projet économique écologique pensez
autrement et à différents niveaux
particulièrement avec la participation
des politiques
des économistes des chercheurs de la
Guadeloupe et de la Martinique que tout
ne soit pas décidé à partir du National
nous vous dirons que
les sciences sociales et les sciences
humaines sont capitales dans ce dans ce
scandale et son capital dans le fait
qu'il faille aussi mettre en place une
démocratie participative à tous les
niveaux via les collectivités via
l'éducation nationale via
particulièrement les cellules familiales
et les associations le créole et la
langue prioritaire en Guadeloupe et en
Martinique mais il existe aussi des
ressortissants qui parlent anglais et
qui parlent espagnol il faudrait que
toute cette communication puisse être à
ce niveau et au niveau de toutes les
personnes et dans les familles au niveau
des quartiers en démocratie
participative avec des personnes qui
sont reconnues avec des Guadeloupe et un
des Martiniquais qui seraient des
ambassadeurs qui seraient formés en
amont et qui pourraient avancer dans les
familles dans les quartiers pour que
tout le monde puisse avoir suffisamment
de confiance laissez tomber la défiance
pour avancer dans la résorption de ce
je vous remercie madame madame Chatenet
rivaudet mais je veux pouvoir donner la
parole et qu'il est aussi du temps pour
Monsieur André Edouard
monsieur Édouard
merci madame la Présidente
après votre collègue
guadeloupéenne avez-vous
encore beaucoup de choses à nous dire
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour le temps
qui m'est attribué et je le respecte
je vous laisse saluer parlementaires
saluer les membres de cette commission
et
je suis le porte-parole du lien nage
vous dépolié et non pas déployer comme
on a pu lire sur certains documents il y
en age ou dépolliez Martinique qui
regroupe des associations des syndicats
des partis et des individuels qui
militent ou la protection de
l'environnement et contre toutes les
pollutions dont les victimes notre
territoire et le combat contre les
conséquences de l'empoisonnement par le
chlore des cônes est un de nos combats
c'est empoisonnement des populations des
Antilles depuis une cinquantaine
d'années et de mieux en mieux connu et
des populations sont passées du
fatalisme à la prise de conscience
active puis à la défiance terme que nous
avons beaucoup entendu ce matin en
vérité du fait de ses conséquences sur
notre mode de vie et sur notre relation
avec les auteurs de cet empoisonnement
d'inscription des plaintes contre l'État
un juge parisien a fait planer la menace
de nos lieux plus de 10000 personnes
descendirent dans les rues pour dire non
à cette menace et pour protester contre
le risque d'impunité des coupeurs
si l'État par la voie du président de la
République lui mais a fini par
reconnaître une part de responsabilité
dans cette affaire il n'a pas désigné
les autres responsables les fabricants
les importateurs et les vendeurs de ce
poison que tout le monde
ceci est vécu par la population comme
une complicité de fait
un autre mouvement a rencontré le préfet
de la Martinique il a parlé de la seule
responsabilité morale je dis bien morale
des acteurs économiques locaux il est
temps ne s'est jamais prononcé sur cet
aspect et n'a jamais laissé imaginer une
perspective de
comment continuer à faire confiance à
nos gouvernements
les plans successifs élaborés depuis
2008 n'ont jamais eu les financements
nécessaires à l'ampleur de la tâche
et les promesses importantes
telles que la traçabilité des aliments
qui est une source d'anxiété autre terme
que nous avons entendu ce matin et la
cartographie des terres polluée sont à
ce jour inachevés la population vit une
anxiété permanente devant son assiette
c'est une drôle de situation
et c'est une nouvelle vie
professionnelle et nouvelle vie sociale
que doivent inventer avec des règlements
du groupe et m'adapter à cette situation
particulière
à la fois les marins-pêcheurs interdit
de pêche côtières et sans moyens adaptés
à la pêche au grand large sans les
mesures d'accompagnement pour le
recouvert
que vivent aussi les agriculteurs et les
maraîchers qui ont les pires difficultés
pour accéder au terrain
déconné nos contaminés et 100 lettres de
l'État les maraîchers qui souffrent
comme les agriculteurs d'une situation
quasi schizophrénique puisqu'on pousse
la population à manger local alors que
la population s'en est faute d'une
traçabilité par toute la piscine
les éleveurs dans les problèmes sont
exactement les mêmes et qui ont déjà été
soutenues le résultat est une fracture
une fracture nette entre l'État et ses
colonies entre la population et les
acteurs économiques
la prolongation de l'utilisation du
glyphosate le report des décisions
européennes sur l'utilisation des
pesticides mines un peu plus les
relations entre la population et les
décides le scandale local récent de
l'utilisation de l'été fond pour
accélérer le mûrissement de certaines
catégories de bananes fait que les plus
sceptiques pensent qu'il s'agit de
moyens de diversion pour faire oublier
le scandale du chlore
jusqu'à quand l'État continuera t-il à
jouer la montre je vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur Édouard
et bien alors je vais donc clôturer
cette table ronde sur les conséquences
sociales et je pense que tous ceux qui
nous ont écouté
ont été
clairement
attends non seulement attentif mais pour
ma part qui est quand même travaillé sur
ce dossier grâce à chacune de vos
interventions j'ai mieux compris
l'anxiété et je pense mais et là je ne
suis pas un décideur je suis à l'Office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques mais
j'ai quand même beaucoup mieux compris
pourquoi ce qui a été mis en place même
si vous l'avez entendu je suis je vais
trouver que c'était un peu lent n'a pas
fonctionné comme ça aurait dû
fonctionner
c'est
effectivement très intéressant alors
heureusement vous avez semble-t-il tous
participé
en tout cas plus au plan que je leur
déconne 4 et
et
il semble que ça évolue enfin après
après quand même trois plans et après
alors je crois que
c'est Madame Châtenay qui a parlé de la
recherche on sait vrai que la recherche
régulièrement sur la NR toujours très
régulièrement aux différents ministres
de l'Enseignement supérieur et de la
Recherche fait par
de ma déception de ne pas voir la
couleur des cône inscrite sur les plans
de l'ANR comme étant une une mission
prioritaire et enfin en 2023 ça commence
mais on sans doute perdu un peu de temps
par rapport par rapport à la recherche
même si nos chercheurs vous l'avez dit
sont très impliqués et sur le plan de la
santé et sur le plan de pour essayer de
trouver comment détruire cette molécule
ou ce serait la seule solution alors je
vais passer la parole si tu as Alexandre
mon collègue avant de lire quelques-unes
des questions des internautes auxquels
vous avez par vos interventions en
grande partie répandue mesdames et
messieurs
merci madame la Présidente déjà je vous
remercie pour vos témoignage
comme madame la Présidente sénatrice je
comprends beaucoup mieux les réactions
qu'il y a eu notamment lors de la crise
sanitaire ou les campagnes de
vaccination avec cette méfiance
vis-à-vis du gouvernement et vous avez
mentionné aussi les problèmes parfois
d'accès à l'eau potable
moi de mon point de vue je trouve ça
impensable que il y a une telle
situation qui soit encore possible au
21e siècle dans un département dans un
département français
moi j'avais des questions plutôt
techniques pour ma collègue sénatrice
madame jasmin
vous avez mentionné
la concurrence entre les produits locaux
qui étaient soumis
aux normes européennes qui n'étaient pas
forcément adapté à la concurrence avec
des produits mais justement comme au
Brésil j'imagine qui ont des normes
beaucoup plus facilitatrices je dirais
moi j'ai travaillé à la douane il me
semblait que dans les départements
d'outre-mer il y avait un régime
douanier particulier et je voulais
savoir si il y avait des mesures
qui ont été pensées ou si le
gouvernement comptait mettre en place
des mesures douanières justement pour
protéger l'agriculture de notre nos
départements d'outre-mer merci
et bien pour le moment ce n'est pas tout
à fait le cas parce qu'on reçoit tous
les produits qui passent à la force de
toute façon pas à la France hexagonale
donc on est dans une situation qui est
assez particulière et en plus il y a une
concurrence qui est liée aussi à
l'octobre de mer donc ici vous avez
entendu parler justement c'est une taxe
qui fait concurrence en quelque sorte
parce qu'au départ
cette taxe c'était pour protéger mais
aujourd'hui et bien contribue une part à
financer les collectivités mais aussi et
permet l'arrivée d'un produit de moins
bonne qualité parce que malgré tout ce
qu'on a pu dire il y a aujourd'hui de
toute façon pour la banane je prends
l'exemple c'est la banane durable de
Guadeloupe et de Martinique parce que
des mesures qui vont être prises à la
fois pour les pour les professionnels
mais aussi il y a quand même des mesures
qui sont prises pour que la de toute
façon la banane qui soit qui est vendu
soit de très bonne qualité mais il y a
une concurrence parce que tous les
produits il y a une méfiance de la part
de notre population justement alors il y
a évidemment les personnes qui avaient
leur jardin que le comme on qui n'ont
plus seulement cette possibilité même
forte de moyens il y en a qui font
peut-être encore de n'importe quelle
manie il y a tous les produits qui
arrivent aussi de façon forte par
rapport aux îles de la carie parce que
il y a pas suffisamment de contrôle de
ce qui arrive sur notre territoire il
faut le savoir parce que là les
douaniers on leur limite ils ont leur
limite parce que nous sommes des îles
nous sommes pour ce qui concerne la
Guadeloupe un archipel la Martinique
nous sommes pourrido et il y a beaucoup
de personnes qui arrivent sur nos
territoires de façon peut-être qu'on
dessine j'en sais rien parce qu'il y a
pas suffisamment de contrôle et les
produits arrivent aussi par ce biais là
donc il y en a qui passe par le secteur
je dirais concurrentiel et qui ont déçu
au coût considérable pour les
utilisateurs consommateurs mais il y a
aussi des produits qui arrivent et qui
sont vendus un peu partout de n'importe
quelle manière et là il faudrait
justement que des messieurs soient
prises pour que nos côtes soient mieux
surveiller c'est compliqué mais les
douaniers on leur limite ils manquent de
personnel et même si même avec toute la
bonne volonté il faudrait que le
problème c'est problématique soit prise
en compte également donc là nous sommes
à la fois dans des territoires à
vocation agricoles et nous voyons très
bien que ça reste très limité parce que
la société d'aménagement foncière a des
limites avec les Plans Locaux urbanisme
il y a encore des limites liées à la
fois au risque naturel majeur et à la
fois aussi à ces problématiques là donc
les agriculteurs on peut on peut de
chance en fait là et nous devons en même
temps parler de souveraineté alimentaire
donc il y a beaucoup de cohérence dans
les dispositifs qui font des politiques
publiques qui sont applicables à nos
territoires
ce que vous voulez intervenir poser une
question non
alors je vais
appuyer les propos que je vienne
entendre parce que dans une autre vie je
suis président du conseil économique
social en développement de la culture et
de l'éducation de Martinique donc c'est
l'équivalent en France c'est des sévères
et
moi j'ai été ce conseil accueille comme
membre le président de la Chambre
d'Agriculture de la Martinique et nous
avons eu en interne ce débat là et je
confirme ce qui vient d'être dit au-delà
de difficultés de contrôle de moyens de
la part de l'État donc il y a le fait
que les
supermarchés à la Martinique et en
Guadeloupe j'imagine sont submergés de
produits importés
et qui vont par le jeu
de maire coûte moins cher que les
produits locaux de bonne qualité et là
on voit très bien que cela
contribue à renforcer les inégalités
sociales qui sont très profondes dans
nos sociétés parce que ce sont les
catégories démunies qui prioritairement
vont se pouvoir le supermarchés avec ces
produits qui sont de fièvre qualité et
qui effectivement
ne sont pas soumis au même nombre
parfois contre que seuls des productions
locales voilà
que bien si plus personne ne souhaite
intervenir alors dans les quelques
questions alors que je retrouve mes
papiers qui avaient été posé ou qui
m'ont été communiqués par le président
de l'OPEX il y avait vous l'avez un peu
évoqué
mais la communication efficace
alors qu'il y a une méfiance de la
population ça j'espère
puisque vous avez chacun participer à
l'élaboration du Plan d'école 4 et que
santé publique France était ici présent
que cette efficacité et les modalités
d'une communication
qui a été celle de l'État depuis une
dizaine d'années va
être une communication plus associative
moins descendante
mais surtout plus efficace parce que on
a beaucoup parlé des jardins familiaux
mais on peut manger dans les jardins
familiaux il faut pas mettre de légumes
racines donc si on met des tomates je
sais pas si on mange beaucoup de tomates
mais on peut manger plein de produits
des haricots des choses qui poussent en
hauteur et qui ne sont pas contaminés
comme les bananes qui ne sont pas
contaminées puisqu'elles sont en hauteur
et c'est tout ce qui pousse dans le sol
une deuxième on a parlé de l'agriculture
une deuxième idée qui me vient
mais j'en parle à la sénatrice ici
présente qui représente le territoire
les territoires antillais en ville on
est sur
on va faire de l'agriculture et on va
produire en ville de l'agriculture en
faisant du hors-sol mais pourquoi est-ce
que
en Martinique ou en Guadeloupe on a
envisagé
dans les jardins familiaux de simplement
faire ce que nous on vend dans les
supers dans les supermarchés écolo et de
dire aux gens vous pourrez continuer à
manger
des légumes de la patate douce et autres
mais pas dans le sol et vous la et on
les aide à faire ce type de culture
puisque culturellement on mange pas la
même chose
là-bas que on mangera dans les pays dans
d'autres pays donc est-ce que il y a cet
accompagnements et je me souviens alors
effectivement vous avez beaucoup parlé
des agriculteurs des pêcheurs
déjà même en 2009 on avait pu mesurer
leur désarroi et encore les pêcheurs ont
commencé simplement à mettre des des
interdictions mais je me souviens d'un
élevage de wassou donc c'était chez toi
en Guadeloupe où il avait plusieurs
bassins il des bassins côte à côte sur
sa terre qui était contaminé et d'autres
ou les Watson n'avaient absolument rien
et on lui a interdit là toute la toute
la culture de wassou alors que il nous
expliquait qu'en sortant ses écrevisses
d'un bassin contaminé pour les mettre
dans l'autre avec la durée de vie que
vous nous avez expliqué
professeur Multinet et ben les wassou
aurait pu être consommés et je sais la
culture
par la culture entre guillemets manger
de la langouste manger des écrevisses
manger des crevettes
il y avait peut-être moyen de faire
autre chose que l'interdiction donc
j'espère que là maintenant on va pouvoir
arriver
dans un autre système en tout cas j'ai
bien noté même si nous on est sur le
plan un peu scientifique mais que vous
réclamez un accompagnement de proximité
un
psychologique et de prendre en compte
l'anxiété qui explique peut-être
pourquoi la communication jusqu'à
présent a échouer et faire en sorte que
puisque hélas on n'a pas trouvé comment
dépolluer les sols ça c'est un fait
scientifique pour l'instant il faut
vivre avec mais comment vivre avec en
protégeant la santé
des Antillais pour qu'il puisse manger
et être exposé le moins possible y
compris
à travers l'eau les filtres à charbon tu
voulais intervenir victoire puis parce
qu'il y a quand même quelques
initiatives citoyennes ou associatives
et il y a les associations par exemple
il y a une qui s'appelle Sanuki Brahim
manger c'est ce que nous allons voir y
manger il y a des initiatives aussi pour
la valorisation des produits locaux par
exemple flûte à pain donc des farines de
frites à pain pour être une altinette
alternative alors avec beaucoup de
usages différents
de plus en plus il y a des associations
itinérantes qui vont sur un territoire
proposé aux personnes de dans quel que
soit leur métier de pouvoir utiliser
d'autres produits et des produits qui ne
sont pas forcément contaminés justement
pour pouvoir s'alimenter pour réduire
également les coûts il y a également
pour ce qui concerne la thématique à la
pêche et éviter qu'il y ait évidemment
des difficultés pour les pêcheurs de
leur programme opérationnel de la région
en Guadeloupe par exemple il y a pour la
croix culture il y a quand même fléchage
donc il y a quand même des initiatives
il faut évidemment que les porteurs de
projets puissent le faire mais il y a
des initiatives qui viennent
d'association par exemple il y a une
association qui avait organisé à la fois
ce territoire de Capestang sous Abi mais
aussi un petit canal avec Monsieur
pancarin
concept qui s'appelait mon jardin sur
mon balcon parce que les gens ont des
balcons au lieu de faire des fleurs
orientales et bien proposer aux
personnes de se mettre dans des bacs sur
le balcon des possibilités de faire de
planter au lieu d'acheter certains
produits qui étaient adaptés et pour les
cultures au sol c'est vrai qu'il y a de
plus en plus de personnes qui se
tournent vers des possibilités de
culture hors-sol sur des terres
agricoles qui ne seraient pas utilisable
pour certaines cultures mais qui
seraient adaptable donc il y a un
certain nombre d'initiatives citoyennes
qu'il faut féliciter et un
accompagnement quelquefois également des
communes si le cas par exemple un petit
canal ou il y a assez souvent il y a eu
le week-end dernier par exemple avec
des initiatives pour permettre aux gens
de mieux connaître justement tout ce qui
a dans le contexte de la biodiversité
c'était sur le territoire des habits
donc avec ses danses club ou il y a eu
plusieurs professionnels de lagriculture
de l'agro économie qui se sont
rassemblés pour permettre aux gens de
mieux appréhender l'avenir en tout cas
et mieux maîtriser leur budget
merci beaucoup alors je crois que
Monsieur Jean-Marie flower
vice-président de l'association BIM
voudrais intervenir et puis on vous
laisse 5 minutes et on va clôturer la
séance
merci madame la Présidente juste
quelques mots de justement de conclusion
tel que beaucoup de pièces du puzzle ont
été ont été livrés ont été échangés
depuis ce matin je vais essayer de les
relier un petit peu
la première il y en a une qui n'a pas
vraiment été cité mais qui est qui a été
soulevé par notre avocat dans l'action
collective conjointe que nous avons pour
la reconnaissance du préjudice d'anxiété
c'est que depuis les années 70 il y a eu
un décrochage de l'évolution de
l'espérance de vie dans les départements
de Martinique et Guadeloupe d'une part
par rapport à l'évolution de cette
espérance de vie dans la métropole
ces deux espérances de vie évoluaient
deux concerts jusque dans les années 70
et bizarrement au moment où on utilise
le chlore des cônes et probablement
d'autres biocides et perturbateurs
endocriniens on observe se décrochage on
observe aussi une prévalence de plus en
plus importante des maladies
métaboliques insuffisance cardiaques
rénale et pratique etc au point
qu'aujourd'hui 2022 nous avons à peu
près un tiers des morts quotidiens donc
trois mots sur 10 à peu près qui sont
liés par exemple à des insuffisances
cardiaques il se trouve que l'un de nos
membres le docteur Mouna édreville
cardiologue a trouvé une publication
scientifique qui établit la
cardiotoxicité du clan des cône un fait
qui n'a pour l'instant pas reçu de
attention particulière en termes de
recherche
scientifique associé à cette à cet
élément
ça peut être très certainement un
élément supplémentaire en plus de tous
ceux qui ont été décrits pour expliquer
tout à la fois le déni d'une certaine
partie des populations le fatalisme
d'une autre partie des populations et la
colère d'une autre partie encore des
populations
concernant cette situation de
contamination pollution empoisonnement
le nom a été prononcé par certaines
personnes en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que au niveau de à partir de à
partir de maintenant et à partir de
dorénavant il nous faut vivre avec ce
pesticide dans nos sols dans nos eaux il
nous faut vivre avec un pesticide dont
on ne sait pas exactement où il est on a
vu que la cartographie des sols non
seulement n'est pas terminée mais en
plus elle est faite elle est organisée
pour être flou pour avoir une vision
floue puisque il n'y a pas suffisamment
de prélèvement par exemple pour avoir
une cartographie suffisamment fine là
après 100 m² près pour justement
adapter au plus près du terrain les
pratiques culturelles
et d'élevage
on a parlé aussi de l'effet cocktail
sanitaire mais je vous ai dit juste un
petit mot de l'effet cocktail
environnemental on a vu il y a comment
l'usage du glyphosate
a favoriser comme herbicide l'érosion
des sols qui eux étaient clans déconnés
et donc le transfert du clan d'école du
milieu terrestre vers le milieu
aquatique et on sait qu'aujourd'hui la
principale cause de l'exposition au cœur
des cônes ce sont les produits d'origine
aquatique les crustacés et des poissons
y compris et surtout la pêche informelle
donc tous ces événements là militent
pour une augmentation de notre point de
vue considérable des moyens qui sont
alloués à ce plan des coins 4 peut-être
même d'ailleurs faudrait-il plutôt
parler de plan perturbateurs
endocriniens puisqu'il n'y a pas que le
Cloud icône
et tant que les choses ne seront pas
tant que
l'État dans toutes ses composantes on va
dire l'exécutif le législatif et le
judiciaire n'auront pas accordé ne se
comprend pas mis en cohérence avec la
responsabilité de au plus haut niveau et
cumuler dans le temps de tous les
acteurs et bien cette parole de l'État
sera toujours accueillie avec une
défiance d'autant plus dommageable que
on a un grand besoin maintenant en ces
temps troublé d'accélération du
dérèglement climatique effondrement
accéléré de la biosphère on a grand
besoin justement de planification qui ne
peut être public et pour laquelle l'État
aura donc un rôle crucial à jouer merci
je vous remercie je vais donc terminer
cette deuxième table ronde
et cette deuxième édition cette deuxième
journée sur la chlordécone
en voulant dire à ceux et à celles qui
nous écoute que en tant que rapporteur
sur ce dossier alopex donc sur l'aspect
scientifique si certaines personnes
veulent m'envoyer des contributions ou
si des personnes veulent que l'on
procède à des auditions complémentaires
il suffit de contacter le père
vous
on peut avant de rendre notre rapport
sur sur le point de situation sur la
chlordécone on peut encore
auditionner certaines personnes on ne
refera pas une table ronde parce que
vous l'avez vu c'est compliqué d'avoir
tout le monde et en plus avec les
horaires donc je voulais clôturer on
remercie en chacun de la franchise de
leurs propos de la clarification qui
nous a été enfin moi en tout cas
personnellement apporté sur cette
deuxième
ronde et qui nous a permis quand on est
comme moi ou comme mon collègue
des métropolitains mieux comprendre
l'approche
et les blocages qui peut avoir en
Martinique et en Guadeloupe je vous
remercie et je vous souhaite une bonne
journée pour les Antilles et une bonne
soirée pour pour nous ici à Paris
merci
[Musique]